so leute ich habe gedacht wir machen heute mal einen außer der reihe eingeschobenen aufwach
stream aber ich weiß nicht wie lange genau mal gucken es ist relativ früh das heißt es geht ja
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon noch ein bisschen aber ich kann jetzt nicht den halben tag stream sondern
auch wenn dort feiertag ist ich muss erst mal kurz was dringend ist noch voll gefuttert von
gestern ich hatte ich habe ja gestern haben was ich sushi gefuttert und zeug ich musste
heute nacht um drei aufs klo ich habe die katze komplett verwirrt so nach dem motto was macht
der kerl um drei uhr nachts auf dem klo die hat danach keine ruhe gegeben die war zu alle fünf
minuten an der tür und hat gesagt jetzt mache auf ist aufstehen hier kommt
man mich ein fünftenspiel jahren
kurz mein tee leer trinken und dann gucken wir uns ein bisschen was an ein schluss zu früh zum
aufwachen was werbung da bringt subscribe subscribe ist natürlich immer gut aber das
bringt dir auch nix oder oder
sieht man keine werbung mehr auf channel so man subscribed hat das kamillentee nix ausgefallen
dass heute richtig pfeifert 25 monate hyper subscription hier oder besser gesagt rege noch
nix mit subscription hat man keine werbung tatsächlich aha das ist immer wusste ich gar
nicht zählt das auch für prime subscription ist es eh so prime subscription war eines der besten
ich glaube dadurch sind einfach so haben sich die subscriber zahlen so irgendwie nicht nur verdoppelt
sondern irgendwie teilweise verdreifacht bei manchen neuen ja und er gibt gibt im out sind
auch top gif im out sind poggers da kann man nämlich zum beispiel an sowas machen wie was
haben wir denn hierfür gibt's zum beispiel dass da so was empfiehlt uns youtube denn heute schönes
clown viel 20 42 prepare wallets ja das haben wir den aufhammer schon
gesehen aus dem von der grafik her sieht es aus als hätten die kranker leute ein battlefield gemacht
das 2.0 was was macht was macht er damit nach 1.0 kommt es in müll du meinst das hier ja das gucken
wir uns auch noch an wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe die haben doch gesagt oder was heißt
die der der creator von battlefield friends die haben doch großartig angekündigt vor battlefield
20 42 so nach dem motto battlefield friends return und bisher ist es einfach nur eine rerun der
alten staffel also gibt es jetzt gar kein neues battlefield friends mehr oder wie ist das ich
mein ich könnte ich könnte es ihm nicht verübeln zu sagen nach dem kack launch scheiß drauf aber
ich frage mich was geplant war du hast dir vier mal zwölf terabyte gekauft weil es jetzt nicht mehr
Weiß gar nicht, was du damit machen sollst.
Ja, Linux-ISOs laden.
Genau, Torrent, Torrent-Linux-ISOs.
Was anderes macht man über Torrent ja auch nicht.
Alternativ kannst du auch Sicherheitskopien speichern.
Ich habe auch letztens einen PC am Straßenrand gefunden.
Da hätte ich auch ein Video drüber machen müssen.
Du glaubst nicht, was als nächstes geschieht.
Einsamer PC am Straßenrand.
Gone wrong, gone sexual.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ich habe es einfach stehen lassen,
weil ich keinen Dreck mit heimnehmen wollte.
Das waren doch IDE-Festplatten drin.
Das haben wir doch.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Exzellent.
Das ist die umgedrehte Variante,
die war zu dem, was wir vorhin gesehen haben.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass der Motor in der Lage ist,
das zu spinnen.
Roter Pfeil mit Thumbnail.
Ja, ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Das muss schon sein.
So, nicht weihnachtlich ist die.
Jawoll.
Pepe, please.
Die Leute haben einfach keine Ahnung.
Die schmeißen ihre PCs weg.
Vielleicht legen sie vorher noch ihren Ordner in Papierkorb oder so
und sagen, jetzt ist alles gelöscht.
Jetzt kann das, jetzt kann das niemand wieder her...
Was habe ich da jetzt eigentlich gelöscht?
An, du.
Wagt es nicht normalerweise, ob man das in den Papierkorb schieben will?
Windows...
Oh, oh.
Ich habe das Meme-Board gelöscht, Leute.
Das sollte ich vielleicht besser,
das sollte ich vielleicht besser da lassen.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Fastest First-Person-Drone-View.
Exzellent.
Gebe ihm.
Okay, das sieht nicht sonderlich spektakulär aus,
aber das ist echt einfach.
Seht ihr mal, wenn es wirklich schnell gehen muss, ohne Lag,
was machen sie?
Analoge Videoübertragung, oldschool.
Low-Res-analoges Video.
Da wird nichts encoded.
Da wird nichts irgendwie 60 FPS, 4K, voll HD.
Da wird analog Video gemacht.
So muss das sein.
Ey, das, dieses, dieses hat,
Das könnte aus irgendeinem billigen Game sein.
Moment, Moment, was ist mit denen los?
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Die Anzeige ist in Meter.
Wo kommen wir dann dahin?
Warum ist die Anzeige nicht in Feet?
Oder in, äh, Ounces?
Oder in Miles?
Warum, warum Meter?
Vielleicht sind es auch Miles.
Man weiß ja nicht, M.
Ja, die Amis haben doch so komische Einheiten.
Warum auch immer noch die das haben, ich weiß nicht so genau.
What's on my home server?
Oder Wolfgang erklärt uns das jetzt.
So ein Video sollte ich auch machen.
Das kommt, glaube ich, gut an.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Was ist auf meinem home server?
Da mache ich ein Video zu.
Länge in Ounces messen, das ist kein Problem.
Bei den Amis geht das.
Dass da wieder irgendwas zusammengeschnitten ist, oder?
Muss der nicht ins Gefängnis?
Oder was ist denn da?
Was ist da jetzt eigentlich rausgekommen?
Anspannung vor Weihnachten.
Ich habe keine VR-Filmchen.
Ich habe generell auf meiner Platte quasi Backups liegen und sonst fast nichts.
Und die Backups mache ich nicht mal richtig regelmäßig, aber ich bin froh, dass ich sie habe.
Ich mache meistens Backups, wenn ich irgendwas wichtiges gemacht habe und mir denke so, ah ok, jetzt wird es mal Zeit.
Jetzt könntest du mal wieder ein Backup machen.
Stirb langsam eins.
Gab es das gestern mal wieder?
Finde ich es immer noch nice.
3D-Drucker-Empfehlung.
Kommt auf den Preis an.
Wenn der Preis egal ist, dann kauft ihr einen von denen.
Die sind richtig nice.
Aber teuer.
Moment, das Darkreader macht es kaputt.
Oh, meine Augen, Alter.
Die Dinger sind halt richtig nice von dem.
Aber ein bisschen teuer.
Die Dinger sind ganz gut, aber teuer.
Ansonsten gibt es noch jede mögliche, ganz viele Möglichkeiten.
Aber ich bin nicht mehr so richtig drin, was diese 3D-Drucker-Sachen angeht.
Ja, ich habe mir vor einer Weile ja auch ein i3 Mega S gekauft, aber der ist jetzt auch schon alt.
Den würde ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr kaufen.
Aber seitdem habe ich mich nicht mehr damit beschäftigt.
Wenn ich was ausdrucken muss, drucke ich was aus.
Und ansonsten, ja halt nicht.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Das ist auch nicht so, dass man den so oft braucht.
Also ich habe gedacht, ich benutze den 3D-Drucker.
Vielleicht ging es ja noch einem von euch so.
Also ich benutze den 3D-Drucker weniger, als ich gedacht habe, vor dem Kauf des 3D-Druckers, dass ich ihn benutzen würde.
Woher soll ich denn wissen, was du willst?
Keine Ahnung.
Wo musst du wissen, was du drucken willst?
Core i5 Schrott.
Im Homeoffice mehr benutzen.
Ja, da habe ich eigentlich, das habe ich nie miteinander in Verbindung gebracht.
Also ich druck ab und zu Gehäuse für irgendwelche Bastelgeschichten mit dem 3D-Drucker.
Ganz, ganz selten mal irgendwelche, Adapter kann man es nicht nennen, so irgendwelche Teile, die man sonst nicht bekommt.
Ich habe beispielsweise ein Netz, nee, das ist kein Netz, ein Sieb gedruckt für unsere Regenrinne.
Weil die nicht so Standard ist vom Durchmesser her.
Aber ich habe es, glaube ich, ausgemessen, wie breit das ist und ausgedruckt, dass nicht so viel Dreck durchschlupft.
Ähm, so Dinger.
Aber das kommt nicht oft vor.
Ja, das kann man auch machen.
3D-Drucker hat halt den Vorteil, dass du auch etwas komplexere Sachen relativ schnell ausdrucken kannst, wenn du nicht gerade der Pro bist, was Holz- und Metallbearbeitung angeht.
3D-Drucken kann halt jeder.
Aus Holz, Metall, was machen kann halt nicht jeder.
Und es geht meistens wahrscheinlich sogar schneller.
Und man muss sagen, 3D-Drucker, wenn die richtig eingestellt sind, ist das Zeug echt, echt präzise.
Wichtig ist beim 3D-Drucker, dass man den ersten Layer richtig einstellt.
Also, dass die erste Schicht gut ist.
Sonst reißt es ab.
Oder es stimmt von der Höhe nicht richtig.
Es passt am Ende nicht richtig.
Der erste Layer ist fast das Wichtigste, was es gibt beim 3D-Drucker.
Wie, ihr habt keine CNC-Maschine zu Hause.
Da gibt es doch immer diese Videos.
Haben wir jetzt schon ein paar geguckt.
So nach dem Motto, cheap, cheap.
Das ist ja nicht nur eine CNC.
Von AliExpress.
So cheap CNC Laser-Gravierer und Dings von AliExpress.
Und das ist dann meistens sehr abenteuerlich.
So nach dem Motto Laser-Gravierer ohne jegliche Schutzausrüstung.
Oder so.
Einfach mal falsch reingeguckt.
Und Augen weggelasert.
Aber es ist halt AliExpress-Standards, ja.
Was haben die meistens drin?
Die haben ja meistens einen CNC-Aufsatz, Laser-Gravur-Aufsatz.
Und irgendwie cutten kannst du damit auch noch oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Halt, halt.
Eigentlich ziemlicher Schrott von AliExpress.
Aber gut.
Zumal die meisten Leute sich das mit Laser-Gravur wahrscheinlich nicht kennen.
Wie bei 3D-Druckern.
Dass man das total oft verwendet.
Einmal verwendet das irgendwie, wenn es hochkommt.
Einmal im Monat oder so.
So, Leute.
Was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
What's on my Home-Server?
Ne, das ist mir jetzt...
Wir gucken uns jetzt...
Ich schieb mir mal einen Bonbon ins Hals.
In den Hals.
Gachi Base.
Und dann gucken wir uns mal das Lego-Video an.
Bock.
So.
Zeit mal, ja.
Requested Lego-Experiments.
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Das dachte ich mir, dass es der Motor nicht drehen kann.
Das ist das erste, was ich gesagt habe.
Das heißt, es wird er nicht drehen können.
Zumal das ja noch nicht mal die richtige, die fertige Übersetzung ist.
Die fertige Übersetzung ist ja sonst wie...
riesig.
Ja.
What happens if you open the jar while spinning?
MonkaS, was passiert?
Few years back I've discovered this.
Was?
Was bin ich sehen?
Was bin ich sehend?
Dass sich der Reifen vom Rad löst oder was?
Ja.
Gut.
Das klappt aber wahrscheinlich auch nur, wenn das relativ elastisch ist und das hier
halt relativ elastisch und sich nach außen drückt.
Dann ist dann halt ein bisschen...
Also es dreht sich schnell, dann drückt es das nach außen und dann hast du halt hier,
weil es elastisch ist, hast du ein bisschen Luft dazwischen.
Curious to know.
If the rated Newton centimeter printed on the housing was accurate...
Moment, ich dachte, das geht jetzt um diese Geschichte hier am Anfang.
Nee, geht's nicht.
She baited, Alter!
Ich dachte, er zeigt uns jetzt, wie hier Massive Huge Übersetzung angesagt ist.
You've got to bait it.
Richtig, she baited.
Weil gerade einer sagt, Speedrun, wir können uns jetzt angucken...
Haus...
Das ist ja auch ein leicht misleading Intro-Bild.
Hahaha.
How Speedrunners Warp Straight Up to the Moon in Majora's Mask.
Können wir uns jetzt angucken.
Dann wissen wir Bescheid.
Viertelstunde.
Bam.
Oh, das ist viel zu leise.
The Legend of Zelda Franchise is famous for its items, quests and dungeons that shape
the way we interact with the world.
As a speedrunner, you want to avoid doing any of that.
Take Majora's Mask, for example.
Die Majora's Mask Speedruns waren ja an sich nie sonderlich geschwind.
Weil du musstest immer halb durch das Game durch.
You're presented with a goal.
Explore the world.
Huge graphics.
Defeat the four dungeon bosses and obtain the remains to unlock the moon and defeat the
final boss, Majora.
Das ist laut genug.
Considering that this game has...
Ich hatte übelst, übelst Schiss, wie ich klein war bei Majora's Mask.
Das ist...
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass das N64, fällt mir jetzt gerade so im Nachhinein auf, kann
das sein, dass das N64 die einzige Plattform ist, die jemals zwei Haupt-Zelda-Titel hat?
Also, der Super Nintendo hat nur A Link to the Past bekommen.
Der N64 hat Ocarina of Time und Majora's Mask bekommen.
Der Gamecube hat nur, und das auch ziemlich am Ende seiner, seiner...
Ne, der Gamecube.
Ja, der...
Ja, das zählt natürlich.
Der Gamecube, der hatte, hatte ganz am Anfang Wind Waker und am Ende seiner Lifestyle hat
er noch Twilight Princess gekriegt.
Und die Wii hatte Twilight Princess und die Wii hatte Twilight Princess und die Wii hatte
Twilight Princess.
Twilight Princess und dann tatsächlich Skyward Sword.
Ne, stimmt nicht, was ich gesagt habe.
Was hatte denn die Wii U?
Ah, die Wii U hat noch, hat noch Dings bekommen.
Breath of the Wild zum Schluss, ne?
Ja...
Ne, dann stimmt das nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hatte ja damals das Glück, ich hatte einen N64, ich musste mir dafür
extra so einen...
Memory Pack?
Bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, wie das Ding hieß.
Ich glaube, da hatte der N64 entweder 4 oder 8 MB RAM danach.
Dann konnte ich mit Majora's Mask spielen.
Und da war ich nicht darauf vorbereitet.
Nach Ocarina of Time.
Ich meine, Ocarina of Time hat den kleinen Max auch schon ziemlich geschockt.
Aber Majora's Mask hat mich echt fertig gemacht.
Egal.
Ja, das hat mich, das hat mir schon, wie ich klein war, überhaupt nicht gefallen, dass
es einen Timer in dem Spiel gab.
Das hat mich immer nervös gemacht.
Zumal es eine ziemlich coole Mechanik hatte.
Das war eines der ersten Games, zumindest die mir so einfallen, wo die ganzen NPCs wirklich
einen Tagesablauf hatten.
Gut, das war natürlich hier alles hardcoded für jeden einzelnen NPC und was wie wo passiert
anhand eben der Ingame-Zeit.
Aber das war schon wirklich cool.
Du konntest ja auch nicht alle Quests überall erledigen und sowas.
Also das war schon nice.
Aber trotzdem, das hat mich immer so psychisch voll unter Druck gesetzt, dass es einen Timer
gab.
Das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, auch wenn mir wahrscheinlich Majora's Mask bis heute
am besten gefällt von allen Zelda-Spielen, die es gibt, ist das immer noch was.
Ich sehe, dass das notwendig war für das Game.
Ja.
Es gibt aber auch irgendwas, was ich nicht vollkommen überzeugend finde.
Egal.
Gucken wir mal hier weiter.
Ja, die waren relativ schnell.
Äh, nicht gar nicht.
Die waren relativ langsam, die Majora's Mask Speedruns.
Ja.
Ich meine, Ocarina of Time ist jetzt runter
auf was? 17 Minuten
oder so? Ne, Quatsch, die haben ja mittlerweile
den Credit Warp
Klitsch. 5 Minuten oder so?
Was ist das?
Wobei
dieses Credit Warps Ding ist halt
komplett sinnlos, ne? Dann spielst
du das Game halt gar nicht mehr.
Ja, 6
Minuten 49.
Das sackt halt irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht, ob mal jemand von euch so
einen Ocarina of Time Speedrun geguckt hat.
Mit diesem Credit Warp Klitsch.
Credits Warp Klitsch.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Du rennst einfach nur durchs Dorf,
machst ein paar Aktionen, um Speicherbereiche
zu überschreiben und
dann klitschst du am Ende bei dieser
Piranha Pflanze oder was das ist.
Ne, das ist Mario bei dieser
Dings, was da aus dem Boden kommt.
Klitschst du durch die Wand und bist in den Credits.
Das ist irgendwie
langweilig.
Da finde ich die anderen
Kategorien tatsächlich spannender.
Okay, jetzt guck mal.
Das klingt auch wieder nach irgendwelchen Memory
League Geschichten.
Und nicht wirklich Memory League, aber
Memory manipulieren.
Das ist bestimmt eklig.
Es zeigt, dass das Gameplay
sehr anders ist als dein
gewöhnlicher Playthrough.
Hey, guck dir seine Maske an.
Er verpasst eine, oder?
Das Spiel erwartet, dass du
Snowhead Village besuchst, um die
Gohan-Maske zu erhalten und eine Lieder spielst,
um die starken Winde zu stoppen, die
Snowhead-Tempel blockieren.
Stattdessen hat Enop einen Glitsch
genannt, den Hyper Extended Superslide,
um es auf den Mountain zu machen.
Hyper Extended Superslide.
Obvios. Alles klar.
Mountain.
Er hat keine Probleme in der Dungeon
entweder, mit Glitschen wie
Super Slide.
Hyper Extended Superslide.
Alles klar.
Easy.
Every major area has ways to skip
items, bypass side quests,
and even get to the bosses
right away.
Large skips are no stranger to
Zelda Speedrunners. By this point,
all of the games had ways to skip a dungeon,
if not all of them.
Unfortunately, this was not the case
in Majora's Mask.
One stubborn requirement remained.
The boss remains, collected from all four dungeons,
were needed in order to reach Majora.
The community found ways
to skip almost anything in the game,
but this one final roadblock seemed impossible.
After five years of using the same route,
most had given up hope that the status quo
would ever change.
Community members would often joke about
wrong-warping to the moon,
or taking this guy's advice and just
bomb-hopping there.
Also, gerade bei N64 Zelda Games
wird mich nix wundern.
Wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie kaputt
Ocarina of Time ist,
und ja die Engine unten drunter mehr oder weniger
die gleiche ist,
und auch viele Glitches ähnlich sind,
und ja die Engine unten drunter mehr oder weniger die gleiche ist,
dann wird mich nix wundern.
Dann wundert mich gar nix mehr bei den Spielen.
Generell muss man sagen,
N64 sind glaube ich mit die kaputtesten,
die es gibt.
Guckt euch Mario 64 und Ocarina of Time an.
Das hat mehrere Gründe, denke ich mal.
Erstens, weil es einer der ersten 3D-Spiele war,
in diesem, wo viel experimentiert war und muss auch,
und weil die Spiele halt saumäßig beliebt und bekannt sind
und auseinandergenommen wurden ohne Ende.
Wenn es ein 3DS Remake ist,
gibt es einige verrückte Glitches,
die gar nicht so nah an der originalen Arbeit sind.
Verrückter.
Nicht alle wussten das.
Ein Team von Glitchhunteren
arbeitete seit einiger Zeit in der Hintergrund,
und sie haben etwas gefunden.
Im August 2019
fand Fash einen Weg, das Debug-Menü anzupassen.
Aha.
Das war ein Abstand aus der Entwicklung,
Obvius.
das die Speedrunner,
jede Sache aus dem Spiel in ihren Inventar einstellen konnten.
Auch die Tideus-Remänen,
die vorher die Dungeons gewinnen mussten.
Oh, okay, okay, ich weiß jetzt schon was passiert.
Oh, okay, ich weiß jetzt schon was passiert.
Sie manipulieren halt ingame
diesen, den Memory-Bereich,
wo drinsteht, wie viele Bosse gekillt wurden.
Okay, das ist glaube ich...
Dann wird das Game wahrscheinlich genauso langweilig, wie...
...das Credit, Credit-Swap-Ding in Ocarina of Time.
Ich finde Speedruns langweilig,
wo das Game nicht mehr gespielt wird.
... für etwas absolut Game-Breaking zu finden?
Das war nicht das, was sie hofften.
Kontroversie entfiel,
wo manche fühlten, dass der Glitch nicht erlaubt werden sollte,
bezeichnend, dass das Debug-Menü
im Gegensatz zu allem, was Speedrunning betrifft, umsetzbar ist.
Das Menü zu akzeptieren, war schmerzhaft,
und benötigte Runners, die Song von Storing 70 Mal in der Reihe spielen,
12 Minuten lang.
Das war definitiv schneller, als alle Dungeons zu zerstören,
aber veränderte das spannende und skilvolle Gameplay
mit dem langweiligen Menuing.
Genau, das ist dumm.
Andere fühlten, dass es, da es im Spiel ohne Cheats zugänglich war,
erlaubt werden musste.
Aber, zugänglich...
... könnte es ein starkes Wort sein,
anstatt das Menü auf N64 zu crashen.
Ich frage mich, wie sie das wieder rausgefunden haben.
Ich meine, wer spielt im richtigen...
... Abstand 71 Mal das gleiche Lied auf der Flöte?
Was ist denn mit den Leuten wieder los?
In 2016, war Majora's Mask-Speedrunner Full Grown Gaming
ein 100%-Run, als das passiert ist.
Du, sprichst du von Squash?
Ich denke, er sollte bald von seinem Examen zurückkommen.
Was? Was? Was? Was? Was?
Hä?
Was?
Was hat er denn für... Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Dass da gerade irgendeine Tür gespawnt ist, oder was?
Was?
Was ist das?
Eine Tür?
Ja.
Seine Kugel schießt einfach eine Tür an, anstatt ein Aero.
Unglaublich, so komplexe Dinge passieren vielen Spielern
und wurden so früh wie 2009 dokumentiert,
aber als eine unerklärte...
Man kann auch mal so eine Tür verschießen,
ich verstehe das Problem nicht.
... bis zum 10. Oktober 2019.
Glitches & Stuff veröffentlichte ein Video von Ocarina of Time,
das darstellt, wie man einen Boomerang an einem Skulltula-Token
im Forst-Tempel ausmacht.
Während man die Kamera ausmacht und in den Raum reingreift,
fliegt eine Tür durch die Luft,
die sich an den Boomerang befindet.
Dieser unerwartete Trick wurde schnell bekannt als
Stale Reference Manipulation, oder SRM.
Bevor ich in die Geschichte hineingehe,
muss ich erklären, wie SRM funktioniert.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig und ehrlich gesagt ziemlich enttäuschend,
aber ich werde es so einfach wie möglich simplifizieren.
Das Programm-Konzept, das SRM verwendet,
ist ein Pointer.
Wie der Name empfiehlt,
schickt ein Pointer die Memory-Lokation
eines relevanten Spiels an,
und sagt, wo die Daten, die es sucht, gefunden werden können.
Jede Programmiererin, die Pointer handelt,
wird dir sagen,
dass sie es einfach machen können.
Wie es so aussieht,
fallen sogar die professionellen Entwickler von Nintendo
zu ihnen.
Es gibt einige Möglichkeiten, dass Pointer verwendet werden können,
aber hier ist ein relevantes Beispiel.
Stell dir vor, dass ein Pointer
irgendwo in der Erinnerung ist.
Wenn die Daten, die mit diesem Pointer verbunden sind,
nicht mehr an dieser Erinnerungs-Lokation sind,
und andere Daten stattfinden,
dann können wir ihn jetzt reinpacken.
Der Pointer sollte gespeichert werden,
damit die Informationen nicht an die unvergleichbare Stelle
in der Erinnerung geschrieben werden.
Aber wenn der Pointer nicht gespeichert wird,
und immer noch benutzt wird,
dann wird die Informationen über das,
was dort passiert, geschrieben.
Im Kern ist das, was SRM tut.
Ich bin...
Das ist schon zu...
Das ist zu früh am Tag.
Da blick ich nicht durch bei der Erklärung.
Versteht irgendjemand, was er meint?
Es gibt einen Pointer,
oder einen ständigen Beweis,
der eine Erinnerungs-Lokation manipuliert,
um Daten zu schreiben, wo sie nicht sein sollten.
Glitches und andere Sachen bestätigen das
mit dem Boomerang-Video.
Wenn du den Boomerang schiebst,
befindet er sich an einem Objekt
und bringt ihn zurück zu dir.
Er macht das, indem er einen Pointer
zwischen dem Boomerang und dem Objekt schafft.
So wird die XYZ-Position des Boomerangs
auf die Erinnerung des Objekts kopiert.
Das schafft die Illusion,
dass beide Objekte zusammenreisen.
Dieser Pointer existiert,
solange der Boomerang veröffentlicht ist.
Und indem man den Boomerang aktiv hält,
aber das, was er gekippt hat, aufgelöst wird,
haben sich die Glitches und andere Sachen
vom Reset des Pointers verhindert.
Was?
Es ist zu früh, oder ich blick nicht durch.
Egal.
Big Braintime.
Wenn das Spiel diese Erinnerungs-Lokation
für andere Daten verwendet,
wird der Boomerang diese Daten modifizieren,
da es glaubt, dass das Objekt, das es trägt,
immer noch in dieser Erinnerungs-Lokation ist.
Also begannen die Glitcher,
sich an die Möglichkeiten zu verabschieden.
Na, wie schrecklich könnte das wirklich sein?
Könntest du dir in diesem Spiel
irgendein Objekt geben?
Nein, es sind die N64-Teller-Dinger,
die sind eh schon schrecklich.
Set Flags to complete quests?
Kein Problem.
Was ist mit Warp to inaccessible locations?
Ein Gemeinschaftsmitglied namens...
Oh, es ist Fash wieder.
Fash theorisierte, dass man SRAM benutzen könnte,
um Owl-Statuen noch mehr nützlich zu machen.
In Majora's Mask gibt es 10 Owl-Statuen,
die weltweit verbreitet werden.
Sie sind meistens benutzt,
um zwischen Bereichen zu arbeiten
und um Progresse zu retten.
Jedes Owl-Statue hat sein eigenes ID-Nummer,
von 0 bis 9.
Wenn man ein Objekt ladet,
enthält es diese Statuen,
schreibt das Spiel die Statue.
Die überschreiben den Counter,
wie viele Dungeons du gekillt hast,
beziehungsweise wie viele Bosse du gekillt hast.
Und dann kannst du wahrscheinlich direkt
am Anfang, wenn du auf den Mond kommst,
gleich das Spiel beenden.
100 pro, so wird das sein.
... Objekt mit seinem ID-Nummer.
Wenn ein Objekt mit seinem ID-Nummer
höher als 9 ist,
beginnt es zu verbreiten,
in seltsamen und unerwarteten Wegen.
Wenn du SRM benutzt hast,
kannst du jeden Wert wechseln, den du willst.
Fashs Ziel war es,
den Southern Swamp Objekt
mit einem ID-Nummer von 14 in 17 zu bekommen.
Alter, was willst du,
Big Brain, ich blick da nicht durch,
ich muss mir das Ende angucken.
... wurde ein Race-Pass
zu einem 23-Minuten-Tutorial.
Jetzt wird's noch abgedrehter.
Dann zum Deku-Palast,
du kannst SRM zu Moonwarp bewegen
und endlich zu Majora kämpfen.
Weltrekord-Zeiten fallen von 30 Sekunden
bis zu 28 Sekunden.
Das ist nur CPU-Status.
6 Minuten, jawoll.
Ich wollte schon immer
an den LED-Panel mir anzeigen lassen,
wie heiß meine CPU ist.
Moinsen, this is Sebastian.
Ist das ein deutsches Video?
Ne.
You probably have already seen
one of those cubes
made of LED-CPU-Panels.
Dieser Chat ist jetzt deutsch.
Well, I wanted to have one too.
Ach so, ist er auch so.
Ja, auch schon.
Last year I had the honor
of giving a talk
at the 36th Chaos Communication Club
on this side.
Zeig mal her.
Those are impressive toys,
especially when you can hold them
in your hand
and the images react
to tilting the cube.
Das war's.
So, I wanted to build one too.
However, I did not want
the battery-powered version
because I wanted to use it
as a deck for...
Die Frage ist halt,
was ist der Vorteil
von einem Würfel mit LEDs,
der mir anzeigt,
wie warm meine CPU ist,
anstatt einfach ein Overlay
auf dem Display zu haben,
wo draufsteht,
wie warm meine CPU ist.
Hm.
Ich meine,
das sieht cooler aus.
Das ist aber auch
das einzig Sinnvolle, oder?
Ja.
Also,
das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
diese dinge was auch immer das sein soll dieser faden da drin das sieht schon cool aus aber ich
würde es mir nicht auf den schreibtisch stellen allein schon war mein schreibtisch immer voll
liegt mit allem möglichen zeug die grafik maschinen und dann wäre er noch voller
jetzt wissen wir bescheid also wenn man nicht wissen wie war unsere cpu ist dann
stellen wir unseren würfel daneben so gucken wir uns mal was maurice zu sagen hat zu 2021
also ich wette mit euch es ist battlefield dabei das muss
ja
muss sein es ist battlefield dabei es ist maurice das heißt es ist auf jeden fall blizzard fails
dabei er soll überlegen was könnte es denn noch sein es ist auf jeden fall battlefield und blizzard
fails dabei gta gta ist wahrscheinlich auch dabei das war ja auch ein riesen aufschrei dieses jahr
battlefield ist kaputt unsere jährliche liste der größten aufreger des jahres macht das mehr
als deutlich ja auch dieses jahr gibt es hier wieder
mehr als deutlich ja auch dieses jahr gibt es hier wieder
mehr als deutlich ja auch dieses jahr gibt es hier wieder amüsante fails und absurde peinlichkeiten
amüsante fails und absurde peinlichkeiten
amüsante fails und absurde peinlichkeiten aber vor allem platz 1 wird jedes jahr
aber vor allem platz 1 wird jedes jahr
aber vor allem platz 1 wird jedes jahr schockierender und alarmiert platz eins
schockierender und alarmiert platz eins
schockierender und alarmiert platz eins ist bestimmt blizzard
ist bestimmt blizzard
ist bestimmt blizzard so kacke so kacke battlefield an sich
so kacke so kacke battlefield an sich
so kacke so kacke battlefield an sich als game ist die ganze geschichte was da
als game ist die ganze geschichte was da
dieses jahr bei blizzard rausgekommen ist bestimmt nummer eins aber umso wichtiger wird es auch
darüber zu reden also legen wir ohne große umschweife los auf morris erzähl uns was sache
ist werbung werbung ich konzentriere mich hier auf neue vorfälle aus dem jahr 2021 ja klar ich
könnte mich hier auch noch mal aufregen warcraft 3 reforged könnte man sich noch ein bisschen drüber
wobei war das ist mein letztes jahr ich immer noch keine ps5 kaufen konnte ach so aber das mache
ich mich dass das interessiert mich nicht ich kaufe mir keine ps5 weil das ist ja ins pc master
race und ich habe mich längst damit abgefunden wie ein mönch der allen weltlichen gelüsten entsagt
wieso er kann ihn gerade auf dem pc spiel und gut ist zumindest zumindest das meiste und es
kommen ja mittlerweile sogar exklusive sachen auf dem pc raus die wollen
jetzt irgendeine uncharted collection raushauen dann horizon zero dawn gibt es auf dem pc den
dhl simulator gibt es auf dem pc also es gibt ja schon vieles exklusive auf dem pc mittlerweile es
gibt gar nicht mal so viel wofür sich unbedingt was würdet ihr sagen leute was ist der kaufgrund
für eine playstation 5 also habt ihr den kaufgrund also was würdet ihr sagen ist das warum man sich
das kaufen sollte um sie zu haben ja um sie zu haben habe ich mit der alten konsolengeneration
gemacht und ich habe mir schon mal die kaufkunden ausgesucht und ich habe mir schon mal die kaufkunden
ausgesucht und ich hatte xbox one und ps4 keine ahnung insgesamt zehn stunden an zusammen oder
sowas die heizt gut das wird sein das ist natürlich das beste mein pc kann aber auch gut heizen wenn
es sein muss ich bin ruhig weiter das glaubt das glaube ich dir nicht morris okay aber seien wir
ehrlich platz fünf pro evolution zocker oder der nachfolger von pro wie heißt das nochmal football
also der pro evolution zocker nachfolger ja das war auch richtig fail neu denn irgendein sportspiel
über das man sich so richtig aufregen kann gibt es eigentlich jedes jahr wenn es reich 2021 waren
es die fußballspiele den anfang machte das neue fifa das eine absolut unterirdische pc version
ablieferte mit kaum spielerischen verbesserungen und grafik wie auf den alten konsolen während es
gleichzeitig einem in it warum war die pc warum war die pc versionen des anderen port von den alten
versionen nicht von den neuen was das schon wieder für eine logik eine viel bessere next-gen version
gibt die aber dem pc in sachen hat weitere anforderungen nicht zutraut aus gründen wer
wahrscheinlich möchte wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wollten sie damit irgendwie konsolen
verkäufert
an kurbeln oder so ja aber warum das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn wenn es und
gerade wenn das auf der ps5 oder xbox series x läuft läuft es auch ohne
großartigen anpassungen wenn überhaupt auch auf dem pc also meinen dass so ein
fehltritt zumindest dem größten konkurrenten pro evolution soccer eine
perfekte tour vor evolution sogar hat richtig reingeschissen dieses jahr aber
richtig reingeschissen einfach selbst fifa ist dieses jahr sogar noch der
kleinste aufreger auf dem fußballplatz denn pro evo gibt es gar nicht mehr
es heißt jetzt e football und ist richtig im arsch namen auch so ziemlich
alles was die serie gut gemacht hat der neue teil punktet wirklich in keiner
disziplin er sieht gruselig aus spielt sich unfassbar zäh bietet kaum spiel
modi und strotzt auch noch vor bugs die quittung e football 2022 schaffte es für
ein
eine weile lang sogar zum am schlechtesten bewerteten spiel wir wissen
wir wissen alle wer zumindest kurzzeitig da ganz oben mit gemischt hat bei
schlechtesten steam games ich glaube battlefield 20 42 ist mittlerweile nicht
mehr top ten aber immer noch weit oben zeiten und wurde erst kurz vor
veröffentlichung dieses videos noch entthront von war of the three kingdoms
einem was für ein ding online spiel das wohl so gieriger pay to win schrottet
das wohl so gieriger pay to win schrottet das wohl so gieriger pay to win schrottet
ist chinesische händler in scharen die steam seite also wenn um uns also wenn
die china chinesen schon sagen es ist pay to win dann ist es aus unserer sicht
schon schon nicht mehr pay to win sondern noch irgendwie was kommt danach
pay to win pay to überhaupt den spawn verlassen können oder so was ist was ist
die steigerung von pay to win weil die chinesen haben da gerne pay to casino
die pay to play ist was anderes das ist schon belegt verletzung der menschenrechte
hey wenn sich die chinesen darüber beschweren dann muss es noch schlimmer
sein also generell muss man sagen in asien
gerade auch in china und und auch teilweise korea ist ja pay to oder vor
allem in china ist ja pay to win akzeptierter als bei uns und wenn die
sich darüber aufregen schon dann muss das wirklich eine ganz extreme geschichte
sein
zwar weiß ich nicht ganz was sie uns damit sagen wollen dass wir immer eine
blitzhund karte auf der stirn haben aber es muss schlimm sein kingdoms kommt auf
miserable zehn prozent positive reviews battlefield 20 42 hatte teilweise 20
prozent oder 21 prozent
aber das ist natürlich noch mal herter ist nur knapp schlechter als iwak
ist nur knapp schlechter als iwak
football
das schafft auch nur 14 prozent von über 25.000 bewertungen und auch auf
metacritic wurde das spiel offiziell zum aber hauptsache aber hauptsache sie
haben fett lizenzgebühren rein gebuttert dass sie die offizielle namen und so
haben können des jahres gekürt konami geld scheint ja da zu sein
musste das große update 10 aber auf frühling 2022 verschieben und es ist
Und es ist irgendwie schwer vorstellbar, dass es diesen Karren noch aus dem Dreck ziehen kann.
Ne.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, warum all das nur für Platz 5 reicht, naja, dann schneid euch mal an.
Platz 4 geht an einen Aufreger, der auch außerhalb der Gaming-Szene Wellen schlug.
YouTube hat eine Dislike-Leiste gestrichen.
Ach, Moment, sowas haben sie da auch mit drin?
Okay, ich dachte, es ging rein um Games.
Okay, dann fällt mir 2021 auch noch ein bisschen mehr ein.
Aber ja, das hat's verdient.
... Videos zwar weiterhin einen Daumen runter geben und der Ersteller kann die in seinen Analytics auch sehen, aber öffentlich sind sie nicht mehr.
Ziel von YouTube sei es, damit gezielte Dislike-Angriffe gegen einzelne Kanäle zu reduzieren.
Eine Analyse im Juli 2021 habe gezeigt...
Ach, das ist... Ich hab mich schon so oft darüber aufgeregt.
Das ist einfach so krasser Schwachsinn.
YouTube macht das nur fürs Geldverdienen unterm Strich.
Ja, weil keine Ahnung.
Ubisoft und Activision und wer auch immer es nicht mag, zu sehen, dass ihr Dreck gedisliked wird.
Und, was auch noch dazu kommt, das ist das eine, und weil die Leute vielleicht abschalten, wenn das Video zu sehr disliked ist.
Also, es hat bestimmt Statisten, die haben bestimmt Statistiken bei YouTube, wo sie sehen können, dass die Leute, wenn sie Dislikes sehen, das Video quasi erst gar nicht mehr ausprobieren.
Was ja auch wahrscheinlich gut ist, weil das Video höchstwahrscheinlich Müll ist.
Du kannst über die APIs... Also, theoretisch kannst du über die APIs nicht mehr abgreifen, aber ich glaube, es geht noch.
Die wollten das eigentlich zum 12.12. glaub abschalten mit der API, aber ich glaube, es geht noch.
Ja, dass das wegen Hatewellen ist, ist halt schwachsinnig.
Dass solche Attacken mit gestrichener Dislike-Leiste tatsächlich abnahmen.
Und nun sind ja Hasskommentare und Dislike-Bombing wirklich Probleme auf der Plattform.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Also, es gibt halt viele dumme Leute auf YouTube, aber Dislike-Bombing, muss ich ehrlich sagen, also, ich will jetzt nicht abschreiten, dass es das gibt, dass sich Leute irgendwie zusammenrotten oder gar irgendwelche Bots kaufen, um Leute da fertig zu machen, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das jetzt nur wirklich verschwindend gering.
Und zumindest ist die Antwort darauf nicht eines der wichtigsten Features für alle abzuschalten.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Ja.
Genau.
Noch mehr.
Ja, ich sag nur.
Diablo Immortal Trailer.
Das Ding hatte auch so heftig viele Dislikes.
Oder neueres Beispiel, das Ubisoft NFT, äh, äh, NFT, äh, Ubi, Ubisoft, ich weiß nicht mehr, unlisted, Trailer, Quartz, Quartz, YouTube, haben wir das irgendwo?
Nein.
Ich brauch den Link da drauf, Leute.
Quartz.
Quartz, wo ist das?
Alter, mir gehen diese Newsposts immer so auf den Sack, die dann keinen Link dazu drin haben.
Hat jemand den?
Ja.
Nein.
Ich will das nicht auf eurer Seite angucken, ich will das auf YouTube gucken.
Ihr werdet, ihr werdet es doch schaffen, dort einen Link auf YouTube, oder ist das mittlerweile gelöscht auf YouTube?
Die werden es doch schaffen, einen Link auf YouTube zu packen, worüber sie sich aufregen.
Das ist ja wieder lächerlich, alter, Newsseiten.
Unlisted.
Tom Henderson schreibt, jawoll, da sind wir doch.
Ups.
Hallo?
Wo ist das jetzt hin?
Ach, da hinten.
Null.
Ja.
1,7k zu 42k.
Das wollen die auch nicht, dass man das noch sieht.
Alter, das ist so schlecht, das ist so mies.
Okay, machen wir das Video weiter.
Zum Beispiel gegen lächerliche Glücksspiel-Trailer, wie dieses Machwerk von NBA 2K20 damals.
Ich meine, nicht, dass sowas groß ist.
Ich meine, nicht, dass so große Firmen je umstimmen würde, wenn der Rubel rollt.
Aber so einem Video darf man schon mal ansehen, wie bescheuert es ist.
Kritik kam sogar von einem der drei YouTube-Gründer.
Das ist das erste YouTube-Video, by the way.
Wer das nicht kennt, das ist das erste YouTube-Video, was hochgeladen wurde.
Javed Karim.
Dem gehört das allererste Video auf der Plattform.
Me at the Zoo.
Karim aktualisierte dessen Beschreibung mit einem Statement gegen die Streichung der Dislike-Leiste.
Nicht alle User gemachten Inhalte sind gut.
Ja, es ist sehr viel Schrott auf YouTube mittlerweile.
Tatsächlich sind die meisten nicht gut.
Und das ist okay.
Die Idee war, dass in dieser Flut an Inhalten großartige Werke darauf warten, ans Licht zu kommen.
Und damit das passiert, muss der Kram, der nicht großartig ist, so schnell wie möglich beiseite geschoben werden.
Das war für Karim der Gedanke hinter der Dislike-Leiste.
Ohne sie werde YouTube in eine Abwärtsspirale geraten und zu einer...
Zumal ihr am Anfang, zu der Zeit, hattet es ja sogar noch das Sterne-System.
Vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch.
Ich kann euch mal zeigen, wie das Sterne-System ausgesehen hat.
Archive.
Org.
So.
Dislike-System.
Achtung.
Äh, äh, äh.
Nicht Dislike-System.
YouTube.com.
Slash.
So, nehmen wir mal meinen Channel.
Nehmen wir mal meinen Channel.
Wayback Machine.
Und gehen wir mal zurück auf, keine Ahnung, 2011.
Und dann hier, keine Ahnung.
Bam.
Oh, gucken wir uns mal einen Channel an von 2011.
Java hat man, äh, nicht Java, Flashplay hat man damals noch gebraucht, okay.
Ist natürlich blöd, dass das jetzt auf Japanisch ist.
Oh, guck mal, da gab's keine...
Da gab's nur schon Up und Down.
Da gab's noch keine Sterne-Bewertung mehr.
Ich bin mir aber relativ sicher, dass es am Anfang noch Sterne gab.
Okay, das ist...
Da hab ich ungefähr meinen Channel erstellt.
Ein paar Monate vorher.
Also.
Da waren's auch schon Likes und Dislikes.
Guck mal.
Da hab ich gar nicht so viel mitbekommen.
Guck mal, da hatte ich noch mal...
Da hatte ich noch den Tux-Keks-Avatar.
Das war das...
Daher kommt auch diese Keks-Geschichte her.
Ich hatte so einen Linux-Avatar ursprünglich drin.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn ich da jetzt sogar Geld mitverdiene,
dann kopiere ich mir keine Bilder, die andere Leute erstellt haben,
sondern lass mir was Eigenes erstellen.
Nein.
Tja, irgendwie sah YouTube doch tatsächlich mal übersichtlich aus, ne?
Du konntest die letzten Kommentare sehen von einem Creator.
Was auch schon sinnvoll war, weil die Leute das vielleicht einfach interessiert hat.
Du hast gesehen, was hier abgeht.
Du konntest Kommentare posten, so sichtbar auf dem Channel.
War eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
So, was ist jetzt, wenn wir hier draufklicken?
Sehen wir's dann?
Aber guck mal, der hat sogar ein bisschen...
Moment, das Video geht noch?
Glaube ich jetzt aber nicht.
Tatsächlich!
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels.
Alter, der Sound!
Can't wait!
Viele von euch wollten ja Gun-Games sehen.
Alter, der Sound!
Deswegen gibt's im Theater...
Oh, ist das schlecht.
Oh, wer hat hier...
Wer hat hier...
Kappa Prime?
Bright Flames gemacht.
Das eigentliche Comment kann man sich nicht mal anzeigen lassen.
Okay, nice.
Guck mal weiter.
... Mäßigkeit werden.
Denn nichts kann großartig sein, wenn nichts schlecht ist.
Aber hey, natürlich gibt's schon eine Browser-Erweiterung, die die Dislikes einfach zurückgibt.
Ja, leider.
Leider können die ja auch nicht zaubern mit dieser Browser-Erweiterung.
Die hab ich ja auch am Start, deswegen seht ihr ja nur Dislikes bei mir noch.
Die haben sich bei Videos in der internen Datenbank angelegt mit Dislikes, als sie noch abrufbar waren.
Und für neue Videos müssen die das irgendwie errechnen.
Das heißt, das wird nie so richtig genau sein.
Mal schauen, ob das auch so bleibt oder YouTube noch dagegen vorgeht.
YouTube hat die API schon abgeschaltet.
Das heißt, eigentlich ist es jetzt mehr oder weniger useless schon.
Man kann es so grob erkennen, weil die die Dislikes errechnen.
Was heißt errechnen? Errechnen ist ja das falsche Wort.
Errechnen würde ja bedeuten, da kommt was so klar, inputbasiertes raus am Ende.
Die sagen einfach anhand der View zu Like Ratio, so und so viele Dislikes müsste das haben, ungefähr.
Die schätzen das eher, genau.
Oh, cringe.
Auf Platz 3 landet...
GTA, natürlich, was soll's.
Die GTA Trilogy Definitive Edition.
Ein großer Titel für eine Neuauflage, bei der eigentlich fast alles daneben ging.
Ja.
Mal angefangen beim Inhalt.
Das größte Verkaufsargument wäre das Grafikupdate.
Aber die neuen Charaktermodelle sind in vielen Fällen eher comichaft und...
Die rechnen hoch, was die Leute liken und disliken mit dem Addon.
Das ist neu, ich hab bei ihnen gelesen auf der Seite, wo sie selbst erklären, wie es funktioniert.
Hier habe ich ja ein Video gezeigt, erklären sie ja, wie es funktioniert.
Und...
Estimated Extrapolated...
Ah!
Okay, das ist neu.
Based on View Like Ratios.
Das scheint jetzt neu zu sein.
Estimates Extrapolated from User... äh, from Extension User Data.
Das habe ich nicht gelesen, oder es ist jetzt wirklich neu?
Ich wusste nur, dass sie das hier machen.
Das ist lächerlich, als wirklich eine Verbesserung.
Ja, es gibt unter anderem neue Effekte, und einige davon sind sogar gelungen, aber andere, wie der Regen, wirken einfach nur so.
Haben die, haben die, haben die das nicht sogar entfernt, zwischenzeitlich?
Haben die nicht das GTA Remake sogar entfernt, um danach quasi, weil es, weil es irgendwie, äh, Modding Code enthielte,
und, äh, um es danach wieder quasi zu entfernen und neu hochzuladen?
Übertrieben.
Und zu allem Überfluss gibt es selbst mit einer GeForce 30...
...80 ernsthaft noch Performance-Probleme bei diesen Uralt-Spielen.
Inhaltliche Verbesserungen, wie die überarbeitete Steuerung, stellten sich dann auch noch als viel weniger tiefgreifend als erhofft heraus.
Und es fehlte sogar...
Und das Schlimme ist ja, dass sie gleichermaßen versuchen, dass man an die alten Spiele nicht mehr rankommt.
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen wie bei Warcraft 3 Reforged.
Keiner wollte es so wirklich haben, gerade von den Pros, die... oder sagen wir mal Pros, ja doch.
Von den richtig guten Leuten, die Multiplayer spielen.
Die wollten ja eigentlich das alte weiterspielen.
Und da hat Blizzard auch gesagt, nö, gibt's das nicht mehr.
...Songs aus den Originalspielen.
Kurzzeitig nahm Rockstar die Definitive Edition sogar offline, weil angeblich noch irgendwelche Dateien drin steckten, die nicht drin sein sollten.
Das alles wäre für saftige 60 Euro schon peinlich genug.
Ja.
Aber viel schlimmer stieß den Fans noch auf, wie Rockstar sie regelrecht zum Kauf nötigen wollte.
Das Studio nahm...
...nicht nur die Originale aus dem Handel.
Ja, ja.
Publisher Take Two verklagte auch noch Modder...
Modder, ja.
...die völlig kostenlos Verbesserungen für die alten Spiele produziert hatten.
Das ist, das ist ja fast...
Also Nintendo ist ja auch so ein Laden, der alles verklagt, was bei drei nicht auf dem Baum ist.
Das ist jetzt aber nochmal eine krassere Geschichte, weil ich meine, die Games wurden jetzt, was weiß ich, 15 Jahre, 10, 15 Jahre nicht mehr supportet.
Und die Leute haben quasi selbst dafür gesorgt, dass sie gut spielbar blieben und auch auf neuere Hardware.
Und jetzt kommen die einfach, ach nö, wir verklagen euch.
...dabei teilweise sogar einen besseren Job gemacht hatten.
Ja.
Hinterher entschuldigte sich Rockstar zwar für das Release-Debakel und brachte die Originalspiele zurück in den Store,
aber der Schaden war angerichtet.
Selbst schuld.
Auf Metacritic...
Komplett, komplett verdient.
Das schlägt jetzt, das spiegelt jetzt vielleicht nicht die reale Sachen wieder, die das Spiel trotzdem verdient hätten,
aber das haben sie sich wirklich verdient.
...steht die Trilogie bei einer Kritikerwertung von 49 und traurigen 0,5 Userscore.
Was tatsächlich noch mal schlechter ist, als Walking on Fire geforcht.
Das haben sie sich, ja, das muss man erst mal schaffen.
...zwar recht knapp, aber hey, Glückwunsch Rockstar, das muss man echt erst mal schaffen.
Das muss man schaffen, ja.
...auf Platz 2 schafft es eine Katastrophe mit Ansage...
Battlefield?
...der Release von Battlefield 2045.
Ich wusste es, ich wusste es, Battlefield.
...schon in der Beta liegt das Spiel...
Okay, wenn jetzt Battlefield kommt, dann ist Final bei Maurice garantiert Blizzard.
...der Release von Battlefield 2045.
Muss, das ist 100%, ich könnte wetten.
...jede Menge Alarmglocken klingeln und ein Monat Verschiebung war viel zu wenig, um die alle aus der Welt zu schaffen.
So ging Battlefield 2042 in einem schlichtweg inakzeptablen Zustand an den Start.
Die Performance enttäuschte selbst auf High-End Rechnern, das Waffenhandling war lächerlich ungenau und es verging eigentlich keine Runde ohne auffällige Bugs.
Zum Beispiel das wundersame senkrecht starrter Luftkissenboot hier.
Zum Beispiel das wundersame starrter Luftkissenboot hier.
Aber mehr noch, viele Fans kritisierten auch grundlegendere Spieldesignentscheidungen.
Grinch-Sprüche.
Allen voran die Streichung der Klassen.
Angel does it again.
Einen der archetypischsten Merkmale von Battlefield als Serie.
Zugunsten der Specialists, die zwar immer noch Teamplay erlauben, aber dazu weniger Anreiz geben als vorher und wirken wie dem Hero-Shooter-Trend hinterhergerannt.
Und die Klassen waren nicht das einzige Feature, das DICE aus dem Spiel warf.
Es fehlten auch essenzielle Funktionen wie Voice-Chat und ein Scoreboard.
Legacy! Legacy-Feature ist das Scoreboard, haben wir jetzt gelernt.
Oder wie Angel sagen würde, don't be sad, that's the way it works out sometimes.
Oder so ähnlich.
Ganz ähnlich wie bei eFootball gab's auch hier eine brutale Quittung auf Steam.
Battlefield 2042 rangiert auf Platz 16 der am schlechtesten bewerteten Spiele der Plattform.
Verdient, verdient.
Und in absoluten Zahlen hat es schon deutlich mehr Spiele.
Am not even shotgun as you are, genau.
Yummy, yummy, ha!
Es kassierte über 70.000 negative Reviews.
eFootball immerhin nur 22.000.
DICE hat zwar schon begonnen, das Spiel fleißig zu patchen und eine Roadmap vorgestellt,
aber dieses Rudern nochmal herumzureißen wird eine echte Mammutaufgabe.
Ich weiß gar nicht warum da so viele zuversichtlich sind.
Bei Battlefield 4 hat das geklappt, ja.
Aber Battlefield 4 war von Anfang an ein gut durchdachtes Game.
Broken as fuck.
Aber ein gutes Game. Battlefield 2042 ist absoluter Schrotthaufen auf Designersicht und vom Zustand her.
Also ich weiß nicht, warum die Leute da so zuversichtlich sind.
Die Steam-Spieler-Zahlen brachen nach Release so gnadenlos ein, dass teilweise der Vorgänger Battlefield 5 auf die gleiche Aktivität kam.
Blau ist Battlefield 5 übrigens, grün ist 2042.
Ich sag's nur nochmal, weil es nicht mehr lange hin ist, dass Battlefield 5 das sogar umdreht und den Nachfolger überholt.
Denn für diesen dicken Anstieg am Ende der Kurve hat Battlefield 5 ein Gratis-Wochenende und einen dicken Sale gebraucht.
Was einen Monat nach Release allein schon ein echt übles Zeichen ist.
Ja.
Ey, soll ich euch mal ein...
Zeigen, der es ähnlich schlecht hingekriegt hätte.
Übrigens, das fehlt mir in Maurice' Liste auch noch, falls es jetzt nicht kommt, aber ich wette mit euch, dass es blizzert.
Es gibt noch einen, der das ähnlich gut hinbekommt.
Mit Spielerzahlen verdient.
Wir sind jetzt unter 100.000.
Leute, an Weihnachten, an Weihnachten, das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Also es ist jetzt quasi die Zeit, wo Leute Zeit haben, spielen können, mehr denn je, als das ganze Jahr über.
Und die haben es tatsächlich geschafft.
Das erste Mal unter 100.000 zu trappen.
Das ist so ein, ein, wie sagen sie immer, ein Train...
Wie heißt das auf Englisch?
Trainwreck oder so.
Also das ist, das ist so im Arsch.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Also New World, das ist einfach mal...
Das war aber auch Fail mit Ansage, ne?
Ist doch noch okay.
Ja.
Aber 92% der Spieler verlieren, das ist sicherlich noch okay, ja.
Stehen geblieben hier.
Aber all das verblasst gegen Platz 1.
Und seien wir ehrlich...
Blizzard, ich wusste es.
Ihr wisst eh schon alle, was...
Wir wussten es.
Es ist Maurice, da musste Blizzard kommen.
Da musste Blizzard kommen.
Aber New World hätte es durchaus da auch noch reingeschafft.
...hier stehen muss.
Keine Firma ist in der Geschichte des Gaming so tief gefallen wie Activision Blizzard.
Und vor allem natürlich der Blizzard-Teil der Firma.
Ja.
Kaum ein Entwickler...
Ich hab letztens, ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen von einem Warcraft-3-Level-Designer.
Und er hat ein bisschen über Blizzard, wo er gearbeitet hat.
Und aktuell im Blizzard geredet.
Und er hat halt zum Schluss gemeint, Leute, hört auf euch da so sinngemäß.
Ich krieg's jetzt zitatmäßig nicht hin.
Der meinte sinngemäß so, Leute, hört auf euch einzureden, dass da noch irgendwas übrig...
Der Easter Egg-Typ, genau den meine ich, genau.
Hört auf euch irgendwie einzureden, dass da irgendwie noch was übrig ist.
Das alte Blizzard gibt's nicht mehr.
Und was ich witzig fand, was er in seinen Videos erzählt hat, dass er vom ehemaligen Blizzard-Chef und von Jeff Kaplan rausgemobbt wurde als Level-Designer.
Also damals war sicherlich auch nicht alles rosig.
Aber Papa Jeff war ja eh früher so der richtig krasse Flamer.
Es gibt ja noch Posts von ihm, ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand sich angeguckt hat, wo er EverQuest 2, das war ja damals, bevor er zu Blizzard gegangen ist, war ja so einer in der besten Raid-Guild von EverQuest 2.
Und der hat so...
Und der hat so krass geflamed im Forum damals.
Würde man von Papa Jeff heutzutage gar nicht mehr erwarten, aber...
Das war auch mal ein junger Flamer.
...einen so unangreifbaren Ruf als die Bastion der Gaming-Perfektion.
Kaum ein Spieler ist nicht zumindest mit irgendeiner Blizzard-Marke aufgewachsen.
Bei mir war es Diablo, das mir am Herzen lag wie wenige andere Serien.
Ich hatte quasi...
Ich meine, die hatten damals einen richtig krassen Rand, muss man sich mal überlegen.
Ich glaube, das Erste...
Ich glaube, das Erste Warcraft-Spiel, ich glaube, das Erste Blizzard-Spiel, was ich gespielt habe, war, glaube ich, sogar Warcraft 2.
Aber die hatten richtig krasse Sachen.
Die hatten von Diablo bis Starcraft, bis dann später Warcraft 3, das war dann auch so, wo ich aufgehört habe, so richtig alles, was Blizzard gemacht hat, zu spielen.
Die hatten so viele geile Sachen.
Also, man hat eigentlich gedacht, die können keinen Mist produzieren.
Alles, was die raushauen, ist geil.
Ja.
Warcraft 2 zu spielen, fand ich nice.
Dann kam Diablo 1, Diablo 1 noch, ja.
Absolut wegweisendes Ding.
Dann kam irgendwann Starcraft, auch ultra geil und natürlich Diablo 2.
Diablo 2 ist, glaube ich, eines meiner meistgespielten Suchtgames aller Zeiten.
Und dann Warcraft 3, das habe ich bei weitem nicht mal so viel gespielt.
Ich habe, weiß ich, fast nur Singleplayer gespielt.
Ich habe ja Warcraft, äh, Starcraft 1.
Habe ich ja sogar Battle.net gespielt damals, aber, äh, Warcraft 3 habe ich nur Kampagne gespielt, war auch ein super Game.
Aber danach war es bei mir mit Blizzard ein bisschen vorbei.
Ich habe, äh, World of Warcraft habe ich nebenbei, neben Dark ein bisschen gespielt damals.
Aber danach, danach war es das für mich mit Blizzard.
Dann kam irgendwann, glaube ich, Starcraft 2 oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, in welcher Reihenfolge.
Hearthstone habe ich auch noch ein bisschen gespielt.
Aber die hatten innerhalb von fünf Jahren, haben die einfach ein, mega krasse Games gespielt.
Krasse Games rausgehauen.
Das ging los, wie gesagt, Warcraft 2 und ging bis, ähm, Diablo 2, Warcraft 3.
Also fünf, sechs, sieben Jahre haben die quasi nach und nach absolut weg...
Stimmt, Overwatch habe ich ganz vergessen.
Natürlich, ihr habt ja recht.
Overwatch habe ich schon wieder so verdrängt.
Die haben diese fünf, sechs Jahre einfach wegweisende Spiele nacheinander rausgehauen.
Das ist jetzt, äh, einfach schon lange vorbei.
Euch waren es vielleicht Warcraft oder Starcraft.
Und deswegen haben uns die letzten Jahre auch so hart getroffen.
Weil Blizzard für viele eben mehr war, als nur ein Erzeuger von Entertainment-Produkten.
Ja, genau.
Blizzard war unsere Kindheit.
Blizzard war eine der tiefsten Wurzeln meiner Gaming-Leidenschaft.
Und ich dachte, nach dem Blitzschrank-Skandal...
Oh nein!
...könnten sie schon nicht mehr viel tiefer sinken.
Ich dachte, nach Warcraft 3 Report...
Es geht immer weiter runter.
...könnten sie nicht mehr tiefer sinken.
Oh, sweet summer child.
2021 verklagte der Staat Kalifornien...
Ich finde das immer noch heftig.
Das musst du erst mal schaffen, dass sich der Staat Kalifornien verklagt.
...weil die Firma Frauen und Minderheiten jahrelang systematisch benachteiligt und misshandelt haben soll.
Gipfel der Anschuldigungen.
Eine Mitarbeiterin soll sich als Folge dieser frauenfeindlichen Kultur auf einer Geschäftsreise das Leben genommen haben.
Das ist so heftig.
Es ist mega heftiges Zeug, wenn man sich damit mal beschäftigt.
Gibt es ja noch viel mehr Sachen.
Und das ist wirklich nur die Spitze des Eisbergs.
Ich kann die ganze Bandbreite der ekelhaften Vorkommnisse in diesem Video nur anreißen.
Wir haben aber eine eigene Talkrunde und einen Sammelartikel zu dem Skandal erstellt, wenn ihr euch ein umfassenderes Bild machen wollt.
Was viele Spieler wohl am meisten traf, war, dass es hier eben nicht nur um die bösen Anwälte...
...und Anzugträger wie Bobby Kotick ging.
Es waren auch viele führende Entwickler unserer Lieblingsspiele.
Die ganz alte Garde von Blizzard, die plötzlich in völlig neuem Licht dastand.
Der ehemalige Blizzard-CEO Mike Morhaime und der langjährige Story-Guru Chris Metzen entschuldigten sich beide für die Vorkommnisse,
aber gaben sich auch überrascht, als hätten sie selbst kaum etwas davon gewusst.
Und beide erhielten Antworten von ehemaligen Mitarbeiterinnen,
dass sie sehr wohl Teil der frauenfeindlichen Business sind.
... und diese aktiv beförderten, selbst wenn sich Frauen hilfesuchend an sie wandten.
Auch in der Anklage steht, dass die Firma und ihre Chefs im Zweifelsfall eher die Täter in Schutz nahmen und die Opfer bestraften, wenn sie...
Ja, weil es mehr Stonks gibt, unterm Strich.
Ja.
Oder man hat sich halt außergerichtlich irgendwie geeinigt, um es bloß nicht an die große Glocke zu hängen.
... den Mund aufmachten.
Bobby Kotick soll laut Ermittlungen des Wall Street Journal sogar feststellen,
dass er Gewaltigungsfälle bei Sledgehammer Games unter den Tisch gekriegt hat.
Ja, ja, das ist das, was ich meine.
Da hat man sich dann außergerichtlich geeinigt.
Und er hat nicht dem Aufsichtsrat danach Bescheid gesagt, was er eigentlich hätte machen müssen.
... gekehrt haben.
Zwar nahmen nach den Enthüllungen viele führende Köpfe ihren Hut oder wurden gefeuert,
darunter Blizzard-Präsident J. Allen Bragg und der Game Director von Diablo 4,
aber trotzdem ließ die Reaktion von Activision Blizzard...
Tja, ich denke mal, Chad, das wird so ein Zwischending sein aus...
... abhängig davon sein, dass man Geld verdient und in Zweifelsfall auch nicht wissen,
wo man sonst was anderes bekommt.
Du kannst ja in der Regel nur Leute richtig ausnutzen,
wenn sie auch noch besonders abhängig von dir sind.
Weil ansonsten sind sie einfach instant weg.
... hat einiges zu wünschen übrig.
Wie Bobby noch CEO sein kann, ganz einfach, weil er fette Kohle macht.
Angesichts stetig wachsender Mitarbeiterproteste hält die Firma etwa an Bobby Kotick als CEO fest
und behauptet, er sei der Richtige, um den tolerantesten...
Ja, bla bla bla bla, was?
Das ist so ein Gelaber.
Das ist einfach nur Bullshit.
Es hat sich ja mittlerweile rausgestellt, dass die...
Die hatten ja irgendeine Frau eingestellt für Integration und Harassment und sonst was
und die sollte sich eigentlich die Sache annehmen
und die hat dann eine Mail geschrieben, wie geil es eigentlich ist, bei Blizzard arbeiten zu können.
Und im Nachhinein hat sich rausgestellt, Bobby hat diese Mail in ihrem Namen geschrieben.
Das hat er sogar zugegeben.
Also, das ist einfach nur komplette Augenwischerei und dummes Gelaber.
Denen geht es nur um Stonks und Geld.
Und wahrscheinlich hat Bobby seine besten Buddys da an den passenden Positionen untergebracht,
dass er nicht so einfach abgesägt werden kann.
... tolerantesten und offensten Arbeitsplatz der Gaming-Branche zu schaffen.
Gleichzeitig erklärte man...
Ja, dazu kann man wirklich nur sagen...
... dass es nicht gut oder schlecht ist.
... Läger vom Kalifornischen Amt für faire Arbeitsbedingungen hätten sich, Zitat,
schändlich und unprofessionell verhalten und ein verzerrtes Bild der Blizzard-Geschichte gezeichnet.
Außerdem geht die Firma bis heute immer wieder dagegen vor,
dass sich die Mitarbeiter zu sehr organisieren und etwa eine Gewerkschaft gründen.
Das ist aber so ein allgemeines Ding.
Guckt euch bei Amazon an.
Ist das gut oder schlecht?
Aber das würde ich jetzt nicht in dem gleichen Kontext sehen.
Dass sie da nicht scharf drauf sind, ist ja bekannt.
... Blizzard nach J. Allen Braggs Abgang eine Doppelführung aus Jen O'Neill und Mike Ibarra an die Spitze von Blizzard setzte,
hielt das gerade mal ein paar Monate bevor Jen O'Neill ihren Hut nahm,
weil die Firma sich nach all dem ernsthaft weigerte,
ihr das gleiche Gehalt zu zahlen wie ihrem männlichen Kollegen.
Kurzum, nichts davon erweckt den Eindruck einer Firma, deren Chefs ernsthaft um Besserung gemüht sind.
Nö, nö, überhaupt gar nicht.
Die so Sachen, so Sachen wie, wir benennen McCree um,
das ist rein öffentliche Marketing-Stonks-Versuche, sich in ein besseres Licht zu rücken.
Nicht, weil man wirklich grundsätzlich was ändern will.
Also mit dem Umbenennen von McCree ändert man sicherlich nicht die Firmenkultur komplett.
Das mag da vielleicht Teil von sein, aber das ist, also diese einzelnen Dinger, die sind einfach nur vorgeschoben,
um zu zeigen, seht her, seht her, wir machen was, um in Wirklichkeit nichts zu machen.
Die Mitarbeiter weiter leidenschaftlich dafür kämpfen.
Und das Traurigste an all dem ist wohl, dass es sich inzwischen nicht mehr wie ein Einzelfall anfühlt.
Das Traurigste daran, für mich so als jemand, der Spiele mag, ist, dass dort auch immer noch Leute arbeiten,
die tatsächlich alles geben, um gute Games zu machen.
Und die trifft's jetzt doppelt. Die haben scheiß Arbeitsbedingungen.
Und im Zweifelsfall verlieren sie noch ihren Job,
weil das Management es so verkackt hat und die Leute jetzt die Games nicht mehr kaufen und sowas.
Das ist ein äußerst vielschichtiges Problem.
Und das ist einfach nur mega für den Arsch.
Und die machen nicht den Eindruck, als haben die irgendwie Bock daran, was zu ändern.
Warum soll der umbenannt werden? Der wurde umbenannt.
Weil McCree wohl nach einem Blizzard-Mitarbeiter benannt wurde, der in diese ganze Geschichte verwickelt ist.
... bis hin zu Activision Blizzard und vielen weiteren Fällen.
Wir alle müssten der Tatsache ins Gesicht sehen, dass die Gaming-Branche...
Ubisoft ist auch so ein Scheißladen. Die haben erst vor einer Woche wieder massig Leute entlassen.
Oder vor zwei Wochen.
So, wisst ihr, das ist doch mal super nett, oder? Mal kurz vor Weihnachten einfach mal Leute entlassen.
Nicht das Kindheitsidyll, nicht der Traumspielplatz, nicht der sichere Ort ist,
den wir uns vielleicht ausmalten, als wir dieses Hobby zum ersten Mal für uns entdeckten.
Ja, Maurice, da hast du recht.
... und dass sie es nie wirklich...
... nie wirklich...
... nie wirklich war.
Nun bleibt nur noch die Frage, wie wir damit umgehen.
Alle recht.
Ist leider so.
Twitter-Empörung, ja.
Das ist typisch, das ist wirklich Twitter.
Genau so ist Twitter.
Das Patriarchat ist daran schuld, kommt klar. Das ist das typische Twitter-Antwort.
How dare you assume my gender?
It says it right there.
Yeah, you'd like that, wouldn't you?
What?
Looks like you're just mad because your time is up.
What does that mean?
You've had all of human history to be happy, so guess what? It's our turn.
We can't both be happy.
Maybe you should learn when to shut up and listen.
Fine, I won't talk.
How dare you?
Who do you think you are?
Are you even aware that silence is violence?
By not talking, you are abusing children.
And puppies.
He's almost worse than Helen Keller.
Oh, I hate her.
How?
She, like, never spoke up once about the...
Wer zum Teufel ist Helen Keller? Das ist irgend so eine Ami-Kakona-Geschichte, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, wer das ist.
... or deaf community.
Like a bitch, maybe you should educate yourself about what's not my job to tell you.
Okay, I'll do some research.
Aber genau so ist Twitter.
Müssen wir jetzt nicht fertig, aber genau so ist es auf Twitter.
Das trifft es ziemlich gut.
Was auch der Grund ist, warum mein Twitter auf Andorra steht und nicht auf Deutschland.
Weil da muss ich mir deutsche Trends angucken.
Und deutsche Trends auf Twitter sind Paints Champ.
Ich werde es euch beweisen.
Ich weiß nicht, was für Twitter-Trends in Deutschland heute aktiv sind.
Aber...
Ich wette mit euch, zwei Drittel davon sind ganz, ganz hochgradiger Paints Champ.
So, zeig her.
Bestimmt Paints Champ.
Weiß nicht, was das ist, aber wahrscheinlich auch Paints Champ.
Ah, okay, es ist Weihnachten, das ist gar nicht so viel so schlimm.
Aber deutsche Twitter-Trends sind einfach abfuck.
Ich hab richtig reingespachtelt gestern.
Gestern war richtig pepofett angesagt.
Extrem.
Pepofett war gestern angesagt.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Was können wir als nächstes angucken?
Ähm...
What's on my home server?
Da mache ich...
Ich mache auch so ein Video.
13 advanced shit-Techniques.
Level-Captcha-Bait, Alter.
Mach nicht so einen Krach.
Warum Autoplay von Videos?
Was ist hier los?
Autoplay in 2021, ja.
What's on my home server?
Okay, zeig her.
Was ist auf deinem Home-Server?
Hi, everyone, and welcome to...
Der Wolfgang.
Now, you guys have asked me for a long time to make a video about what I run on my home server in terms of software.
And I planned to make this video about two weeks ago, but unfortunately...
Der Wolfgang ist am Start.
...because of me moving out to different apartments, it was delayed and...
Ungefähr so...
Also...
Ungefähr so sieht mein Schreibtisch auch gerade aus.
So, geht in die Richtung, ja?
It was delayed, and as you can hear, there's a lot of echo in the video, so I'm sorry if that's too disturbing, but we're gonna have to live with that for now.
So, let me just open the home page of my server here, at homer.box, and first things first...
Hab ich gar nicht.
Ich hatte auch mal so ein Dashboard, aber ich hab's nie verwendet.
Okay, lass mal gucken, was hat er denn?
Ähm...
Jellyfin?
Das ist irgend so ne...
Downloader-Geschichte, oder?
Oder?
Oder ist Jellyfin...
...eine Plex-Alternative?
Ich bring das grad durcheinander.
Ich glaub, das hier sind beides Downloader.
Ich glaub...
Also, Radar und Sona ist auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Torrent-Download-Geschichten, oder so.
Deluge, weiß ich jetzt nicht, was es ist.
Openbox klingt halt wie...
Im Prinzip ist das hier wahrscheinlich das, wo er seine Sicherheitskopien speichert.
Werden natürlich nur...
Und Linux-ISOs.
Also, das hier ist für Sicherheitskopien und...
...Linux-ISOs.
Passwort-Manager, Foto-Manager, ja, File-Sync, Kalender-Sync.
Für seine Netzwerk...
Netzwerk-Geschichten, wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich WLAN-Controller und...
...und falls er Kameras hat, aber wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich WLAN-Controller.
Zum, äh, manchen Jacket, keine Ahnung.
Fritzbox ist klar.
Äh, Pi-KVM ist auch klar.
Pi-Hole, gut.
Äh, DNS, Adblock, Gedöns, Foscon.
Das ist ZigBee.
Gedöns und Home-Assist sind.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir eigentlich schon alles.
Müssen wir uns gar nicht angucken.
Wir skippen das jetzt.
Wir skippen jetzt fort zur Home-Automation, weil ich glaube, der Rest ist nicht sonderlich spannend.
Das ist ein Media-Server, das...
...ein Ding, das ich auch ein separates Video machen muss, weil es...
...ein ganz großes Thema ist auf seiner eigenen Seite.
Aber ich werde es euch kurz zeigen.
Also Foscon GW ist nur eine Web-Interface...
GW, warum nicht KegW?
...ConB2-USB-Stick.
Ja, ZigBee.
Wenn ihr euch nicht mit ZigBee-Devices kennengelernt habt, das ist, you know...
Ja, das verwende ich unter der Haube auch.
Also ich habe, ähm, einen, äh, ConBee 2-Stick.
Das ist vom gleichen Hersteller, der auch das macht.
Wobei ich nicht das hier, nicht die Cons verwende, sondern, ähm...
...SigBee 2 MQTT.
Once again going to be a huge rabbit hole.
And I'm sure I'm going to talk about it at some point.
But basically just lets me adopt new ZigBee-Devices.
Klappt sein ganzes Home-Automation-System noch, wenn das Internet ausfällt?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das ist ja der Vorteil, wenn er das lokal mit ZigBee-Geräten macht.
Also meins geht auch noch, wenn das Internet ausfällt.
Wo es bei mir nicht mehr geht, ist, wenn ich meinen Home-Automation-Server ausschalte.
Hier.
And I also have thermostats and stuff.
But a place where the most Home-Automation for my house is taking place is right here.
It's Home Assistant.
And as you can see, I got a lot of stuff here.
And I can just basically, äh, turn off my lights like this with just one click.
So viel hat er da gar nicht drinne?
Der hat ein paar Thermostate.
Okay.
Die Standard-Sonne ist auf, ist untergegangen.
Und ein paar Lichter.
So viel ist da gar nicht dabei.
I can...
Also, also ich hab bei mir das ähnlich wie er, nur dass ich's raumbasiert hab.
Also ich hab hier das Arbeitszimmer.
Moment, ich mach's mal kurz auf.
Aber so, dass ihr's nicht sehen könnt, weil da ist zu viel Leak.
Ich hab ein Dashboard.
Home-Dashboard, da sieht man, wer daheim ist.
Und der Batteriestand und Außentemperatur und, äh, Müllkalender und offene Fenster und Heizungsdruck im Keller.
Äh, Tankstellen in der Nähe.
Heizungstemperatur, das hab ich auf dem Dashboard.
Dann hab ich, äh, fürs Arbeitszimmer...
Äh, fürs Wohnzimmer nen Tab.
Dann hab ich fürs Arbeitszimmer und Serverraum nen Tab.
Dann hab ich fürs Klo einen extra Tab in meinem Home Assistant.
Weil mein Bad braucht, äh, einen extra Tab.
Dann hab ich die Küche drin.
Und den Keller.
Und den Stall.
Im Stall ist ein Temperaturfühler für den Fischteich.
Und ne Steckdose.
Turn on the...
Big lights, I can turn them off, I can make it...
Ja, Rabe Dennis, deswegen machst du's auch nicht, ob er irgendwelche China-Chinesen klaut.
...hotter in my room, because I also have smart thermostats, I can make it colder, etc.
This is all, I think, pretty cool, you know, a lot of, you know, good quality of life things.
And the reason I'm not running some kind of, you know, a cloud-centered...
Nein, mein Klo hat keinen Methan-Sensor.
Wär aber mal ne gute Idee.
...off-the-shelf solution, like maybe Ikea-Smart-Home-Stuff or Philips, is because I want to have full control over my...
...off-the-shelf solution, like maybe Ikea-Smart-Home-Stuff oder Philips, is because I want to have full control over my...
...smart-home-devices.
Mach doch mal ein Screenshot von deinem Home Assistant.
...without heating if one of those services goes down.
Okay.
I want it to be absolutely self-sufficient, I want it to work without internet, even if nothing else works, even if I don't have any internet, I want my heating to still work, obviously, you know, like, just like any normal heating.
But I also want to have those nice-to-have things where, you know, if you go out of the room, you're like, ah, I forgot to turn on the light, but now I'm too lazy, and then you just do this, and bam, the light is off.
und bam, die Lichter sind aus.
Ich weiß, es klingt wie ein paar Erste-Welt-Probleme,
du bist zu müde, um die Lichter aufzulösen,
aber ich sage es einfach, es war ein Spaß-Projekt für mich
und ich denke, ich werde versuchen,
mehr und mehr meiner Heimat smart zu machen,
nur um es zu tun, nicht weil ich zu müde bin,
sondern weil es einfach Spaß macht, weißt du.
Also werde ich dich definitiv auf das veröffentlichen
und du solltest ein Video über Smart Home sehr bald erwarten,
welches in meinem Kanal-Language vielleicht dieses Jahr ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann nichts versprechen.
So yeah, that's actually it.
Those are all the services that I run.
Muss ich das alles zensieren, ja.
I also want to tell you about those green and red indicators.
They're supposed to indicate whether a service is up or down,
but because of a lot of HTTPS and core shenanigans,
it doesn't work as expected.
For example, Nextcloud reports that it's down.
Ich copy-paste euch jetzt mal.
Ich hoffe, ich habe alles zensiert.
Ich copy-paste euch mal hier meinen Home Assistant-Dashboard.
So, so sieht das Dashboard aus, wenn ich das Ganze aufmache.
Ich habe hier oben eine Anzeige für, wann der Müll kommt.
Da stehen normalerweise die Tage unten drunter.
Dann habe ich eine Anzeige Luftdaten,
die aber gerade aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
da steht dann so Feinstaub, Feinstaubbelastung und sowas drauf.
Weiß ich nicht, warum das gerade nicht funktioniert.
Kein Schimmer.
Außentemperatur, dann Anwesenheitsstatus,
dann wann der nächste Zug kommt nach Frankfurt,
dann die Batterieladung, das geht normalerweise noch ein bisschen weiter nach unten,
dann die Batterie von den ganzen Geräten.
Das hier ist verbuggt.
Weiß ich nicht, warum das auf 0% steht.
Das funktioniert noch.
Und das ist frisch gewechselt, die Batterie.
Die müsste eigentlich...
90% haben keine Ahnung, das ist irgendwie verbuggt, aber der Rest passt.
Dann habe ich hier das, was wir zusammenprogrammiert haben im Stream.
Der Heizchamp ist am Start, Heizung an, aus,
Temperatur, aktuelle Temperatursensor im Flur, der das ausliest.
Dann habe ich Anzeige Fenster oben, unten.
Auf zu, also sprich, ist die Haustür auf zu, ist das Bad oben unten auf zu.
Es gibt einen Wasserleak im Keller.
Ich kann den Heizungsdruck, ich kann quasi neues Wasser auffüllen per Knopfdruck im Keller.
Da habe ich dieses Ventil-Ding dran gemacht, was wir uns im Stream angeguckt haben.
Ich habe mir noch eins gekauft.
Also ich habe jetzt unten im Keller quasi das, was wir versucht haben im Stream, was nicht funktioniert hat.
Jetzt kann ich quasi ein Ventil aufmachen mit so einem Drehmotor, mit so einem Motor, der so was...
Äh, was heißt denn?
Welf auf deutsch, so ein Ventil.
Zum auf und zu macht.
Kann ich Heizungsdruck auffüllen.
Dann sehe ich die nächsten drei Tankstellen, was es da gerade kostet.
Dann sehe ich Verbrauch vom Haus insgesamt, was gerade irgendwie auch ein bisschen der Kraft packt.
Und dann habe ich für jeden Raum, der relevant ist, habe ich einen eigenen Tab.
Das ist das Wohnzimmer.
Das ist mein Arbeitszimmer.
Das ist das Klo.
Das ist die Küche.
Das ist der Keller.
Und das ist der Stall im...
Am Garten.
Und hier ist die Übersicht für die ganzen Kameras.
Was ist das für ein Ventil und wie liest du den Heizungsdruck aus?
Äh, ich lese den Heizungsdruck nicht aus.
Äh, ich habe eine Kamera an dem Druck, an der Druckanzeige von der Heizung.
Da kann ich einfach auf die Kamera gucken.
Und wenn das dann quasi unter 1 fällt, dann drücke ich hier einfach drauf.
Und dann geht das Ventil im Keller auf.
Und füllt Wasser nach.
Jo.
OCR und automatisch gibt es sogar fertige Sachen, aber ich habe keinen Bock, das doppelt zu machen.
Ähm, hast du für alles...
Äh, Bahn, Tanken, eine AP oder Scrapes oder etwas selber?
Ähm, die verwende...
Das ist in Home Assistant eingebaut.
Also, was ich hierfür verwende ist...
Äh, Home Assistant...
Moment, Home Assistant...
Ich mach mal kurz Musik an.
Sek.
Home Assistant Tankerkönig.
Tankerkönig.
Home Assistant.
So, das da.
Das Home Assistant Tankerkönig Add-on.
Da kannst du dir...
Kannst du deinen Wohnort angeben.
Und der sucht dir...
Ups.
Und der sucht dir dann die Tankstelle in der Nähe raus und zeigt dir das an.
Wann es aktualisiert wurde, steht normalerweise noch drunter.
Was es da gerade kostet.
Wollte ich jetzt gar nicht zeigen.
Das Add-on brauchst du.
Und für die Bahn ist auch relativ einfach.
Weil Home Assistant...
Home Assistant hat eine offizielle Bahn-API-Integration.
Also sprich...
Ja.
Sprich, ähm...
Da trage ich ein Abfahrt...
Ort, Ankunft, Zielort.
Und dann sagt er dir die nächste Verbindung.
Ja, und das ist hier komplett selbst gebastelt mit der Heizung.
So, und ihr seht, ich hab hier alles doppelt und dreifach.
Ich hab Z-Wave-Sachen am Start.
Ich hab Zigbee-Sachen am Start.
Ach ja.
Diese...
Diese Anzeige, beziehungsweise die Daten für die Müllabfuhr,
das verwendet ein Add-on.
Das kann ich euch mal zeigen.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Das nennt sich...
Muss ich mal kurz nachgucken.
Hier tab Waste Collection Home Assistant.
Waste Collection Schedule.
Ja.
Und...
Warte mal, die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, oder?
Okay, so ist besser.
Ja, normalerweise stehen hier unten die Tage, wann das abgeholt wird.
Da steht dann, keine Ahnung, Biotonne in zwei Tagen, Plastiktonne in vier Tagen und das in zwei Wochen und sowas.
Und als Datengrundlage nimmt er das hier.
Das ist tatsächlich relativ...
Relativ Big Brain gemacht.
Ich muss gerade mal gucken, irgendwie gibt es da noch Alternativen.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Ach nee, das ist ein Frontend.
Das ist ein Frontend dafür, glaube.
Oder?
Nee, genau.
Ich verwende das in Zusammenarbeit mit, ich glaube, Müllmax.
Oder so.
Zumindest sieht man hier, der hat für Germany ganz viele Provider, wo man abfragen kann,
wenn man seinen Wohnort einträgt, wann die Müllabfuhr kommt.
Das heißt, man muss sich da auch nie wieder drum kümmern.
Das aktualisiert sich quasi am 31.12.
Aktualisiert sich das automatisch.
Auf den Müllkalender für nächstes Jahr.
Ja, du kannst es auch per ICS-Datei machen.
Wenn du dir einen Kalender runterlädst.
Aber du kriegst so gut wie ganz Deutschland hiermit irgendwie abgefackelt.
Weil das hier sind ja so Meta...
So Meta-Dinger.
Die für verschiedene Orte gehen.
Dann nicht? Okay, Pech.
RIP.
Ja, so schaut mein Home Assistant aus.
So, gucken wir mal sein Video weiter.
Das speichere ich mir mal kurz hier, weil das interessiert bestimmt noch mehr ab und zu mal.
So, was kommt als nächstes?
Other Stuff.
Ja, juck mich nicht.
Okay, OS. Was hat er?
Ubuntu!
Äh, wo hab ich's denn?
Jibantü!
Warum?
Ja, Ubuntu bin ich auch voll ganz dafür.
Ubuntu ist es einfach... Ja, seh ich auch so.
Ja, genau.
Deswegen mach ich das auch so.
So mach ich das auch so.
Wie gesagt, ich hab auch meinen Ubuntu-Server und einfach...
Ich mach dann da drauf, äh, eine VM für meine Smart-Home-Geschichte und ein paar Container für den Rest.
Fertig, aus, Schluss.
Und Unraid expect you to do everything through GUI, so things like setting up docker containers or storage can't be efficiently automated.
A bare-bones Linux-Distribute with a command-line interface just works better for me and gives you more freedom and flexibility.
As for storage and file systems, my hard drives are formatted in XFS.
And I'm using a MergerFS-Array to combine them into one big storage pool.
Okay, das hab ich nicht.
MergerFS lets you use drives with different power...
Das hab ich nicht, weil, wozu auch, ich hab nur eine große 12TB-Festplatte dran, da muss ich nix merchen.
...Systems and even different capacities, and you can also add more drive to the pool after the fact.
I'm also using a 1TB NVMe drive as a cache.
MergerFS doesn't have a native support for cached drives, but there is a cool little guide on the MergerFS GitHub that outlines a workaround for that.
I've set it up so that files are moved from the NVMe drive to the cache.
Okay, brauche ich nicht, weil, ich hab nur eine 12TB-Platte.
Und ich hab da noch zusätzlich über USB einfach eine Platte dran, wo ich, äh, in R-Sync mache.
einmal die nacht das ist zwar absolut ghetto im vergleich zu den coolen sachen die heutzutage
machen kannst aber es ist easy as fuck und es funktioniert
das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch ich habe auch die meisten sachen ich habe ein größeres
docker compose file und da ist eigentlich alles mehr oder weniger
drin
das
solange ihr das nicht irgendwie von außen erreichbar macht ist das eigentlich ein fast
nicht existierendes problem erst wenn die dinger von außen erreichbar sind
und
Meme, ihr kennt ja die Zange
Wie, das ist überhaupt nicht dabei
Also die beste Firewall ist
eine Zange, die das Kabel durchknipst
Aber man muss ja auch hier unterscheiden
zwischen
Deine Anwendungen können von innen in das
Internet zugreifen und die
Antworten können zurück
Versus
Man kann aus dem Internet darauf zugreifen
Das sind ja zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe
Und wenn deine Anwendungen ins Internet
können, ist das das eine
Aber was
nicht gut ist, ohne dass man weiß
was man macht, wenn man vom Internet
auf deine Anwendungen kommt
Das eine schließt ja das andere
aus, also nicht aus, also
nicht automatisch mit ein
Also wenn deine Anwendungen auf das Internet zugreifen können
ist ja nicht automatisch, dass das Internet auf deine Anwendungen zugreifen kann
So, und sobald man
das macht, dann muss man sich schon
genau überlegen, was man macht
Aber die meisten brauchen das gar nicht
Kaum jemand muss wirklich
Seine Smart Home Sachen von unterwegs mit dem Smartphone steuern
Und wenn, dann kann man immer noch das ganze über VPN machen
Sodass man die Anwendungen selbst nicht ins Internet stellen muss
Oh, jetzt kommt hier Big Stonks IP-Table
Mit HTTPS, SSH und all den anderen Porten, die du absolut brauchst
Du kannst Firewall D, UFW, IP-Tables oder was auch immer du möchtest
Statt deiner Web-Applikationen direkt zu bewegen
solltest du etwas wie eine Reverse Proxy nutzen
Persönlich benutze ich
Swag, secure Web-Application-Gateway
Was für ein Ding?
It automatically fetches and renews the SSL-Certificates for all the domains
Includes fields
Warte mal, Swag ist diese Nginx-Geschichte von Linux-Server, oder?
Ach ja, ja, ja, das kenne ich
Swago, Swag
Ne, das ist Swagger
Das ist wieder was anderes
Wie meinen das hier?
Swagger, das benutze ich nicht
Ich habe einen Traffic Reverse Proxy
davor der Zertifikate händelt
Ja, brauche ich nicht
Einfach root Passwort 123, easy, reicht
We'll see an authentication gateway
Othelia supports two-factor authentication as well
with either TOTP or UTF
which is a great way to protect your Web-Services
Now you don't necessarily need single sign-on
on all of your public Web-Services
that already support
Ja gut, public Web-Services gäbe ich ihm ja voll und ganz recht
Aber ich habe ja keine public Web-Services
für mein Smart Home und solche internen Geschichten
or two-factor authentication
such as Nextcloud or Bitwarden
But if you're especially paranoid about unauthorized access
to your services, you should definitely take a look
One other thing that you could do
for your security and privacy
is using a Cloudflare proxy for your Web-Services
If you're hosting public-facing
services from home, you don't necessarily
want everyone to
Also ich würde gar keine public-facing
services at home, ich würde gar keine public-facing services at home
hosten
Das ist das Erste
Aber ein Cloudflare DNS
oder generell eine Domain
und einen passenden DNS dafür
den man benutzen kann
für Zertifikate ist tatsächlich sehr praktisch
Ich habe mir auch ein paar Domains
registriert und eine davon verwende ich
für daheim und ich habe es einfach
so eingestellt, dass mein Router
diese Domain prinzipiell
Wildcard auf
also alles was zu dieser Domain gehört
bei mir ist das eine Domain, das ich
mir auf meine 2 HE Serverkiste
weiterleitet anstatt ins Internet
Im Internet lösen die Dinger auch gar
nicht auf und ich benutze die Domain
das ist eine ganz normale public
auflösbare Domain, also die gibt es
das ist also ganz normal offiziell
registrierte Domain und die DNS benutze
ich um Let's Encrypt Zertifikate zu
generieren, also sprich ich habe für
alle meine internen Services dadurch gültige
Let's Encrypt Zertifikate, was ich
äußerst praktisch finde und ohne sich
irgendwie ein bein auszureißen
Let's Encrypt is easy as Fuck
selbst gebaute Zertifikate und CA ist halt
Paintschamp das musst du dann überall
installieren und manche Browser mögen
das mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr
deswegen einfach Let's Encrypt und gut ist
Cloudflare
basically proxys your HTTP and HTTPS
traffic through their own servers so that
the Domain name for public services don't
Das kann man machen, ja.
Ja, Moment.
Die proxien das.
Aber wenn die deine Public-IP rausbekommen,
können sie trotzdem auf alles zugreifen,
wenn du es weitergeleitet hast.
Also ich würde einfach generell nie
Public-Services daheim hosten.
Und wenn, dann nur hinter einem VPN.
Fertig.
Da kann dir eigentlich nicht viel passieren.
Das habe ich, also mein VPN
habe ich damals sogar anders gelöst.
Ich habe mir keinen
Dynamisch-DNS-Eintrag gemacht.
Ich habe mir damals
einen 2-Euro-Server gemietet
bei irgendeinem Hoster.
Und habe per Auto-SSH
ein Port-Forwarding gemacht
auf meinen VPN-Eingang.
Ich glaube,
das ist nicht die schönste Variante,
aber da bin ich um Dynamisch-DNS rumgekommen damals.
Da hatte ich quasi
einen Public-Server,
der mich auf meinen SSH-Intern weitergeleitet hat.
Auf meinen VPN-Geld
bei Intern weitergeleitet hat.
Wo würdest du dann
zum Beispiel am eigenes Nextcloud hosten?
Lokal, bei mir auf irgendeiner Kiste.
Es sei denn,
du hast wirklich den
Anspruch,
dass du Public-erreichbare Links
sharen willst zu deiner Nextcloud.
Dann musst du es
irgendwie von extern erreichbar machen.
Aber dann würde ich tatsächlich
mir überlegen, ob ich nicht zwei aufsetze.
Eine im Internet
für alles, was Public geshared werden soll
und eine für mein internes wichtiges Zeug.
Ich würde meine Nextcloud nie
ins Internet stellen.
Ich weiß, das machen einige,
aber ich bin da absolut kein Fan von.
Und man hat gesehen, wie einfach
sowas zu knacken ist.
Spätestens ein Log4J. Gut.
Nextcloud ist PHP, die hatten das Problem nicht,
aber das kann da
genauso passieren.
Even if it changes.
Tabby? Ist Tabby nicht ein Terminal?
If you don't have a Cloudflare proxying
and don't have your own domain name,
your main name is DuckDNS.
You can get a free domain name like
domainname.duckdns.org
and updating your IP address is as easy
as setting up a cron job.
They have instructions for every setup imaginable,
so make sure to check it out.
If you have your own domain name,
the client is probably the way to go.
Ja, und wenn du dann, also wenn du wirklich
für irgendwie Public, um Sachen zu sharen,
was weiß ich, stell dir, wenn man sich vorstellt,
du bist Fotograf und willst den Leuten
über deine Nextcloud die Bilder sharen einfach nur
dann musst du das Extent irgendwie hosten.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel mal
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner in den Chat eingeben
und da kannst du dir einen 20 Euro Startgutschein sichern
für Hetzner Cloud.
Da kannst du dir dann einen Server mieten
und da dann Zeug drauf installieren.
Aber da würde ich dann keine privaten Sachen drauf schmeißen.
Namecheap hab ich auch.
Ich hab, ähm,
also ich hab zwei Sachen. Ich hab einfach
porkban, das ist so der billigste, schlechteste
Domainregistrar, den es gibt.
Ähm, und
dann hab ich Namecheap.
Also
Cagway Services läuft über Namecheap.
Von Hand.
Ganz ehrlich, das kann man,
wenn man eine Kiste daheim hat,
auch heutzutage ohne Probleme
immer noch so machen.
Für, ich sag mal, reproduzierbare
und vor allem
nachvollziehbare Sachen
nach 1-2 Jahren, wenn man sich dann
selbst fragt, was hab ich denn da
eigentlich gemacht, ist so eine
Ansible-Config, gar nicht mal so blöd,
weil darin ist dann quasi
automatisch der Aufbau automatisiert
und du kannst nachgucken,
was du gemacht hast.
Das ist gar nicht so blöd.
Auch wenn es erstmal wie Overkill wirkt,
weil du richtest deinen Server ja eigentlich nur einmal ein,
aber allein schon, dass du nachgucken
kannst in einem Jahr oder zwei noch mal,
was hast du da eigentlich gemacht,
ist so dein Ansible-Playbook vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Moin.
Moin Freigas, danke für den Sub.
Setting up a new machine is a pretty boring process
that can sometimes take several weeks of
fine-tuning, troubleshooting and googling.
Several weeks ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Don't remember, you never have to do it again. Right?
Well, yes.
Passwortmanager, ich hab keypass seit Ewigkeiten.
Many ways in which things can go wrong.
Drive failure, natural disasters
and just simply working your installation
beyond repair. Happens to the best of us.
And besides, I don't know about you guys,
but after I install Linux on a server and use it for some time,
it kinda feels dirty.
Like, I don't know what's on it anymore,
and I don't have any control over it.
So I always have this issue to reinstall it,
make it cleaner, less bloated and better this time.
There is also another problem.
When setting up a new Linux machine,
I personally tend to come across issues
that are not so easy to diagnose.
But once I solve them, I immediately forget how I did it.
So next time I have to reinstall,
I get the same issues again
and I have to go through the whole troubleshooting process again.
And I think I found a way to set up my server
in a cleaner, less bloated and overall better way.
It's called Infrastructure as a Code.
Infrastructure as a Code is a philosophy of managing configurations...
Ja, im Prinzip sowas wie Ansible.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Was hat er? Ansible, sag ich doch.
Was sonst?
Ich bin echt froh, dass sich Ansible
aus dieser ganzen Masse so ein bisschen
abgehoben und durchgesetzt hat.
Weil ganz ehrlich, Puppet,
also wir haben auf der Arbeit relativ viel Puppet
oder auch Chef,
ist ja auch so ein Ding, das haben wir aber nicht.
Das gibt es ja schon richtig lange.
Oder auch CFEngine.
Das war ja so der Vorreiter der Sache,
falls sich das irgendjemand mal angeguckt hat.
Ich finde, von allen diesen Lösungen, die es da gibt,
ist Ansible immer noch die angenehmste.
Keine Frage für mich.
After all, things like setting up users,
partitioning and mounting hard drives,
or installing packages,
can definitely be achieved by Shell Script, right?
So, why Ansible?
Well, let's start with item potency.
Item potency is the ability to run a program multiple times
and have it produce the same result,
regardless of the system state.
Here's a very simple example.
Let's create a folder with mkdir.
As you can see, running it once works as expected.
The folder is created.
But if we run it again, we'll get an error,
because the folder already exists.
However, if we add the dash p flag to the command,
we'll see no error.
So now the command is item potent.
However, in other cases, this might not be as easy.
For example, some package managers will complain
if you try to install a package that's already installed.
And in a lot of other cases, you'll have to add error conditions,
write if loops, and so on and so forth.
However, with Ansible, item potency is baked in.
Ansible will not change its state.
Ansible hat das schon alles programmiert für einen.
... your system, unless there are changes to be made.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Was ist die Mischung von Terraform und Ansible?
Terrible.
As with shell script, you'll need to constantly reinvent the wheel
and add extra checks and conditions to make sure your code is item potent.
With Ansible, you don't need to worry about that.
Next up, readability.
Ansible playbooks and tasks are way better in terms of readability
than you ever should have.
Also, wer gestern oder wann war das vorgestern im Stream dabei war,
da haben wir selbst wieder ein bisschen Ansible-Zeug gebastelt.
Das ist einfach praktisch.
Und zumal, wenn man damit beispielsweise Cloud-Server aufsetzt,
wie wir schon öfters im Stream gemacht haben,
du brauchst halt nur kleine Anpassungen
und kannst immer wieder das benutzen, ja.
Du musst dir gar keine großartigen Gedanken mehr machen.
Du nimmst dein Ansible-Skript,
editierst den Namen vom Service-File,
editierst drei Sachen, führst aus, gut ist.
Guck mal letztens vor zwei Streams,
wie einfach wir,
ich kann es dir nochmal zeigen,
ich mach das jetzt einfach auf,
ich zitiere mich jetzt einfach mal selbst,
wie einfach wir hier,
ähm,
was deployed haben auf der Linux-Kiste,
guck mal.
Ja, war relativ am Anfang.
Ja, guck mal.
Das ist alles, was wir machen mussten.
Wir haben das, wir haben das Create,
da ist der Chat ein bisschen im Weg jetzt,
natürlich blöd.
Jetzt hat jetzt keiner gesehen.
Ähm,
wir führen einfach nur aus,
Server erstellen
und danach lassen wir das Ansible-Playbook laufen.
Und wenn ich das, ähm, ausführe,
dann ist das Server einfach,
dann ist das Server einfach gleich da.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum manchmal Leute
auf einmal nichts mehr schreiben.
Das ist, weil die sehen wollen, was ich im Terminal habe.
Vielleicht soll ich den Chat irgendwie anders platzieren,
bei sowas.
Guck, Server aufgebaut,
Server erstellt sich automatisch
und jetzt, Max, schalt mal zurück.
Und jetzt
wartet er 20 Sekunden, dass der Server oben ist.
Rechts oben könnten wir den Chat machen, ja.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
So, und guck, jetzt läuft
der komplette Aufbau
des Systems durch.
Der macht, ähm,
ach Mist,
jetzt gucken wir gar nicht zu.
Jetzt mach ich irgendwelche Musikstells
anstatt
während er aufbaut. Ja, aber guck,
der Server baut jetzt auf.
Updating Packages, updated things,
installiert Packages,
so, und das alles mit einem Ansible-File,
was eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger
fertig war.
Das ist der completion of the
complement to shell scripts,
was heißt, das ist auch leichter zu verwalten.
Ansible ermöglicht, eure Taskennamen zu geben,
die reflektieren was sie tun,
und fast jedes Modul hat sehr intuitive Parameter.
Die Struktur von Ansible-Projekten kann
ohnehin ziemlich zutreffend sein als erstes.
Aber als du keine Dokumentation lest,
führst du viel Klarheit,
eine andere Grund, weshalb ich Ansible
zu Shell-File verwende, ist das bündne Secret-Management.
Ansible Vault lässt sie kreieren,
encrypted Variablen, die nicht in plaintext estatten,
Ja gut, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht ankommen.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken, aber ich finde es schön zu sehen, dass man da jetzt wieder erkennt, dass es halt auch für einen Server insofern sinnvoll ist, wenn ich nach zwei Jahren nachgucken will, was hast du da eigentlich gemacht oder wo hast du das jetzt hingelegt.
Du guckst in ein Ansible Playbook und du weißt halt gleich, was Sache ist.
Ich habe einen Link zum GitHub-Report.
Also das erste, was man machen muss, ist, wenn man seinen Bootsektor kaputt machen will.
DD, IF gleich, DEF 0, OF gleich.
DEF, SCA, BS gleich, 4K, COUNT gleich 1.
So, und dann ist der Bootsektor weg.
So.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt ja nur gültig bei seinem lokalen Setup.
Ja.
Gut, das kann man machen, wobei ich sagen muss, das finde ich passt schon für einen lokalen Server dann wirklich zu viel des Guten, weil ich meine, braucht man wirklich ein automatisches irgendwie Setup für einen Server, den installierst du ja nie neu.
Den installierst du höchstens neu, wenn dir die System-SSD verreckt.
Weiß nicht, ob das so sinnig ist.
... so I will go back to the terminal and run the Ansible Playbook called run.yml, which will set up my server from scratch.
It will create the users, update all the packages, mount the drives, install Samba, NTP, Docker and all the necessary packages, restore the persistent data for all the Docker containers and bring them back up.
It will also harden the SSH access and change the default port from 22 to 69.
As usual, I will leave a link to the...
Das ist gut.
Default port 69.
... repository with the Ansible Playbook in the description...
Perfekt, ja.
... and if you'd like to see a separate video with a step-by-step walkthrough and a deep dive into my infrastructure as code setup, make sure to leave a comment below.
Ja, haben wir schon geguckt.
And there we go, impressive, right?
Here's what I'm supposed to say, don't try this at home, kids, but actually, do try this at home.
Take a look at my GitHub repository and see if you can adopt infrastructure as code yourself.
It's gonna change your life.
Instead of having so-called snowflake servers with unique configurations that can't be reproduced...
Wupp S.
... and take a long time to recover in case of failure,
IAC makes your configuration resilient, idempotent, easily reproducible and portable.
Now, Ansible is mostly used in professional Linux environments to deploy multiple machines with similar configurations.
But even if you only have one machine, it definitely helps to keep your setup tidy and easily reproducible.
Find ich auch.
Also, ich find das sinnvoll, gerade, dass du nachgucken kannst, auch nochmal nach zwei, drei Jahren, was hast du denn gemacht?
Ich glaub, letzte Woche haben wir das geguckt, Chat.
Aber dieses Setup an sich...
Okay, ob man das jetzt braucht?
Besides, it's a good job later.
So that's going to be...
Okay, nice.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ups, was hab ich dazu gemacht?
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Half-Life 2 League, oh nee.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Da hat man rausbekommen im Half-Life 2 League, dass vieles von den Sachen, was angeblich AI war, auch nur gescriptet war und sowas.
Gucken, was uns YouTube noch vorschlägt.
Du-du-du-du-du-du.
Ehe so, juckt mich so überhaupt gar nicht.
Singleplayer MMOs, lull.
Das Teleskop startet doch jetzt irgendwann, oder?
Das ist doch jetzt irgendwann demnächst.
Zwei Stunden, Leute.
Monka S.
Monka Launch.
Guck ich mir nachher an.
Wie's launcht.
Es sind zwei Stunden, bedeutet 13 Uhr 20.
Das sieht nicht nach einer SpaceX-Rakete aus, oder?
Wo starten die denn?
Französisch Guyana oder irgendwie sowas wieder.
Sitzen da Menschen drinnen? Nö.
Wie findest du das Spiel? Ready or not?
Sagt mir nix.
Ach, ist das diese, ähm, Tactical-Polizei-Einsatz-Stelz-Geschichte?
Ja.
Das hat ziemlich gute Bewertungen.
Das hab ich auch schon gesehen auf Steam.
Aber ich kauf mir prinzipiell keine Spiele, die Early Access sind.
Nee, wir schauen den Launch nicht im Stream.
Weil ich geh gleich off und dann Mittagessen.
Ja, ich kauf mir keine.
Es soll wirklich gut sein, aber ich kauf mir keine Early Access-Spiele.
Hat jemand ne Idee?
Ich, also ich frag jetzt wirklich, ich weiß, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Oder ne Vorstellung davon?
Wie viele der Early Access-Spiele, also wie viele der Anteil der Spiele, die als Early Access auf Steam rauskommen, jemals Early Access überhaupt verlassen?
Und voll released werden?
Also ich würde drauf tippen, vielleicht 20%.
Was würdet ihr sagen?
Wie viele Spiele verlassen 69%?
Wie viele Spiele verlassen Early Access wieder?
Oh.
Äh, QSC, kein Blassenschimmer.
Only 25, da war schon mit 20% gar nicht so schlecht.
Und ich dachte auch schon, 20% sind relativ hoch.
Ich hatte auch gedacht, wahrscheinlich eher unter 10.
Weil ich mein, es gibt so viel Bullshit.
Und das meiste davon ist auch noch Early Access.
Ja, gucken wir uns dann, gucken wir uns, also ich, also wir nicht zusammen.
Ähm, guck ich mir dann um 13 Uhr, guck ich mir das an, wie gestartet wird.
So Starts können ja immer noch mal relativ kurzfristig abgesagt werden, wenn zu schlechte Wetterbedingungen oder sonst was.
Hat das Video einen Chat? Ja.
Es gibt aber mehrere Videos.
Europa fahrt runter.
Was?
Soll das nicht fährt runter heißen?
Europa fahrt runter?
Was ist das für ein Satz?
Koste spare.
Sind die Schwaben wieder am Start?
GTX 660 TI.
Ja, aktuell kannst du alles gut verkaufen, was ne Grafikkarte drin hat.
Leute, ich glaube am 31.12. sind die Tage für den Preis-Champ gezählt.
Ich glaube, dann schalte ich das ab.
ZG.
Ok, Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Schön, dass ihr kurzfristig dabei gewesen seid.
Runde geschwätzt.
Morgen gibt es wieder Wachen Stream, weil morgen ist ja Sonntag, der Preis-Champ keine Ahnung.
Ja, oder so?
Ich hab' doch ein Twitter-Post gemacht.
Ja, ungefähr ein Ja.
Das ist doch in Ordnung.
Der Preis-Champ hat auch einen Changelog.
Guck, das letzte Mal was gemacht habe ich am 01.02.
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.